Well, you guys know we love Airbnb. I also just did a ladies' birthday trip. It was my friend's 50th birthday. All of us gals drove up the coast. It was so fun. We had the kitchen to hang out in, but then we all had our own space because, you know, we love each other, but I mean, I kind of want my own space at night. You know what I'm saying. We love the privacy. They're always in such great locations where you can really get to know the town you're in. And there's some real hidden gyms out there. These little pockets and neighbors, that you might not see if you stayed at a hotel. Listen, I could go on and on about Airbnb because I love it. It's a great way to travel with friends and family. And you know, your home might be perfect for Airbnb. If you frequently travel or have extra space, maybe you go out of town at the same time every year for a family trip, your home could earn you money while you're away. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca.ca. slash host. With Instacart, you get groceries that over-deliver, so you can over-share your preferences. Want russet potatoes with no brown spots?
好吧，你们知道我们很喜欢Airbnb。我最近也刚参加了一次闺蜜生日旅行。那是朋友的50岁生日。我们这群姐妹开车沿着海岸线一路北上。真的太有趣了。我们有厨房可以聚在一起，但每个人也都有自己的空间，因为，你知道，我们虽然相亲相爱，但我晚上还是想要一点私人空间。你懂我的意思吧。我们很看重隐私。Airbnb的房源位置总是很好，让你能真正了解所在的城镇。而且还有一些真正的隐藏宝藏。这些小角落和邻里，如果你住酒店可能根本发现不了。听着，关于Airbnb我可以滔滔不绝，因为我太喜欢它了。这是和朋友家人一起旅行的好方式。而且你知道，你的家可能也非常适合做Airbnb。如果你经常出差或者有空余空间，或者每年固定时间去外地家庭旅行，你的家可以在你不在的时候为你赚钱。你的家可能比你想象的更有价值。去Airbnb.ca/host看看能赚多少钱。有了Instacart，你可以买到超乎预期的杂货，这样你就可以尽情分享你的偏好。想要没有褐斑的褐皮土豆吗？
You got it. Want turnips that look light, but feel heavy? Easy. Want honey-crisp apples that are firm, green, and definitely not Macintosh like last year when you lost the fall bake-off to perfect Penelope Johnson? Okay, a bit TMI, but we're here for it. So download the app today and get $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply.
没问题。想要看起来颜色浅但拿起来沉甸甸的芜菁吗？简单。想要那种结实、翠绿，而且绝对不是像去年那样让你在秋季烘焙大赛输给完美佩内洛普·约翰逊的那种脆甜苹果吗？好吧，这有点信息过载了，但我们乐意效劳。所以今天就下载APP，前三单享受0美元配送费。Instacart，超乎预期的杂货配送。服务费、排除条款和条件适用。
Welcome back to Second Drink of Fun Run Part 2. I mentioned this last week. I loved these episodes so much. I had such a blast filming my scenes for Fun Run. Well, we got to get out of the office. We always enjoyed sunshine. We talk about that. I really love the pictures from this episode.
欢迎回到《Fun Run》第二部分的第二杯欢乐时光。我上周提过这个。我太喜欢这些剧集了。拍摄《Fun Run》的场景时我玩得特别开心。嗯，我们终于可以走出办公室了。我们一直很享受阳光。我们聊过这个。我真的很喜欢这一集的照片。
I have so many. We brought our cameras, but also NBC sent photographers out, and they got a ton of behind-the-scenes moments. They're still on the end. NBC website. I saw one of Greg talking through a scene with me and John. And Angela, there's such a sweet one of you and Steve just walking and talking. It just, it really made me miss us. Yeah. I miss our little hangouts between scenes, especially when we're on location. And this was especially fun because we
我有好多照片。我们带了相机，NBC也派了摄影师，他们拍了很多幕后花絮。它们还在NBC网站上。我看到一张格雷格和我还有约翰讨论场景的照片。还有安吉拉，有一张你和史蒂夫边走边聊的照片特别温馨。真的让我很怀念我们在一起的时光。是啊。我怀念我们在场景之间的小聚，特别是在外景拍摄的时候。这一集特别有趣，因为我们
were coming back from a summer break. So we were all real chatty. Yeah. Well, we can't talk about fun run and not discuss sprinkles. Our IP sprinkles. Yes. And you. And, you know, we got a lot of mail about whose fault it really was for Sprinkles' death. We discussed this in our episode all about Angela Martin. We had said maybe if Pam hadn't made Angela go to the hospital in the first place to see Meredith, that Sprinkles would still be alive. But Angie Z wrote in and said this. I don't think Pam was responsible for Sprinkles' death.
刚从暑假回来。所以我们都特别健谈。是啊。好吧，我们不能聊《Fun Run》而不提Sprinkles。我们的IP Sprinkles。是的。而且，你知道，我们收到了很多关于Sprinkles的死到底该怪谁的邮件。我们在关于安吉拉·马丁的那一集里讨论过这个问题。我们当时说，如果帕姆当初没有让安吉拉去医院看梅雷迪思，Sprinkles可能还活着。但安吉·Z写信来说：我不认为帕姆该为Sprinkles的死负责。
It was definitely Dwight's fault. You can clearly see how much he doesn't care about doing the tasks that Angela asked him to do for her cat. He probably didn't do it right. because he wasn't even paying attention when she was telling him how to give sprinkles her medicine. Most definitely, Dwight's fault. I appreciate it. I do. I really took on as Pam some of that responsibility after our all about Angela Martin episode.
这绝对是德怀特的错。你可以清楚地看到他根本不在乎安吉拉让他为猫做的事。他可能根本没做对，因为当安吉拉告诉他怎么给Sprinkles喂药时，他根本没在听。绝对是德怀特的错。我很感激。真的。在关于安吉拉·马丁的那一集之后，作为帕姆，我确实承担了一些责任。
Well, it is true. I mean, she gave Dwight a whole written-out list. All he had to do was look at it. Exactly. Well, in this breakdown, we also talk about how the documentary crew pulled Jim and Pam into the conference room to show them footage that proves their dating, and it got us wondering, why is the documentary crew getting involved when there's so many examples of them not getting involved? Well, Ashley S had a theory that I thought was interesting. Ashley says, I figured out why the crew intervened to force a romantic admission out of Jim and Pam,
嗯，这是真的。我是说，她给了德怀特一张写得清清楚楚的清单。他只需要看一眼就行了。没错。好吧，在这个解析中，我们还要谈谈纪录片摄制组是如何把吉姆和帕姆拉进会议室，给他们看证明他们在约会的录像的，这让我们很好奇，为什么纪录片摄制组要介入，明明有那么多例子显示他们并没有介入？嗯，阿什利·S有一个理论，我觉得很有意思。阿什利说，我弄明白了为什么摄制组要干预，强迫吉姆和帕姆承认恋情，
while previously leaving Andy to float away at the lake. Guys, it is so obvious. They are asking to get the scoop for their boy Brian. Oh, yes. Do you think? I mean, at this point, though, aren't they couples friends? No, because Jim and Pam aren't like a couple yet. So they're not a couple yet. And Pam is single. I guess, but isn't Brian married? We don't know when Brian got married, I guess. We don't know. Okay. I mean, Ashley, I think it's a fun theory. It's kind of a stirring the pot kind of theory. It really is. All right. Well, I wanted to address this question from Anna M. Anna says, why wasn't Angela's funeral lady in mourning garb mentioned as part of the wardrobe breakdown? It seems like the perfect missed opportunity. Anna, you're so right. I can't believe
而之前却任由安迪在湖上漂走。伙计们，这太明显了。他们是为了给他们的哥们布莱恩挖独家新闻。哦，真的吗？你觉得呢？我是说，到了这个阶段，他们难道不是情侣朋友吗？不，因为吉姆和帕姆还不是情侣。所以他们还不是情侣。而且帕姆是单身。我想也是，但布莱恩不是结婚了吗？我们不知道布莱恩是什么时候结婚的，我想。我们不知道。好吧。我是说，阿什利，我觉得这是一个有趣的理论。这是一种唯恐天下不乱的理论。确实是。好吧，我想回答安娜·M的这个问题。安娜说，为什么安吉拉在葬礼上穿的哀悼服没有在服装解析中提到？这似乎是一个完美的错失机会。安娜，你说得太对了。我真不敢相信
I missed that costume breakdown. So here you go. Angela's morning outfit consists of a black silky camisole covered with a sheer black lace long-sleeved blouse with black pipe. it has a scrunched high collar and lots of tiny black buttons down the front and the sleeves have this kind of scrunched poof at the end like a poet's blouse pair that with a black skirt and an updo and there you have angela's morning outfit such great detail by our costume department well one last thing i wanted to share this deleted michael talking head because we're going to find out what famous philanthropist michael says he looks like This is really funny. Yeah, the charity is having some financial problems. What do I look like to you? Paul Newman? That's actually not a good example
我错过了那个服装解析。所以给你补上。安吉拉的哀悼装包括一件黑色丝绸吊带背心，外面罩着一件透明黑色蕾丝长袖衬衫，带有黑色滚边。它有一个褶皱的高领，前面有一排细小的黑色纽扣，袖子末端有那种褶皱的蓬松感，就像诗人的衬衫。搭配一条黑色裙子和盘发，这就是安吉拉的哀悼装。服装部门的细节做得太棒了。好吧，最后一件事，我想分享这个被删减的迈克尔的采访片段，因为我们要看看这位著名的慈善家迈克尔说他长得像谁。这真的很有趣。是的，慈善机构遇到了一些财务问题。你觉得我长得像谁？保罗·纽曼？这其实不是个好例子
because I have been compared to a young Paul Newman, my eyes and my face, and I make my own salad dressing. I mix Newman's ranch with Newman's Italian, salad at flea markets for a slight loss. I could make a profit if I could make a profit if I changed one of the ingredients to wishbone, but I won't do it. Yeah.
因为我曾被比作年轻时的保罗·纽曼，我的眼睛和我的脸，而且我自己做沙拉酱。我把纽曼的牧场沙拉酱和纽曼的意大利沙拉酱混合在一起，在跳蚤市场上亏本卖沙拉。如果我把其中一种配料换成Wishbone，我本来可以盈利的，但我不会那么做。是啊。
Yeah, he looks like Paul Newman. He has a side hustle of selling mixed salad dressings at a flea market for a loss. What? I mean, lady, Paul Newman is known for his blue eyes, piercing blue. Yeah, I mean, Steve has like hazily eyes. I mean, it's nice eyes. Sometimes they look green. Sometimes they look brown to me.
是啊，他长得像保罗·纽曼。他还有个副业，就是在跳蚤市场上亏本卖混合沙拉酱。什么？我是说，亲爱的，保罗·纽曼以他的蓝眼睛闻名，深邃的蓝眼睛。是啊，我是说，史蒂夫的眼睛是淡褐色的。我是说，很好看的眼睛。有时它们看起来是绿色的。有时对我来说看起来是棕色的。
Mm-hmm. They're not Paul Newman's eyes. Well, don't tell Michael that. But I feel like that's so true. You know, everyone has a friend who thinks they look like someone really famous, and you're like, I don't see it. I mean, it's so reminding me of the love is blind and the poor woman who said that people tell her that she looks like Megan Fox and, like, the guy on the other side of the wall
嗯哼。那不是保罗·纽曼的眼睛。好吧，别告诉迈克尔。但我感觉这是真的。你知道，每个人都有一个朋友，觉得自己长得像某个大名人，而你会想，我怎么没看出来。我是说，这让我想起了《爱情盲选》里那个可怜的女人，她说别人告诉她她长得像梅根·福克斯，然后墙那边的那个家伙
is, like, loses his mind. Like, he can never think of dating anyone else in the pods because he thinks he's going to leave with Megan Fox. And I mean, I get some of the resemblance, but I mean, I don't know what the comparison would be, but I mean, it's just like, it's a big leap. Okay. I mean, like, you want to be accurate, especially when you're, like, dating, like, in the pods. I mean.
简直要疯了。他根本没法考虑和别人约会，因为他觉得他要和梅根·福克斯一起离开。我是说，我能看出一点相似之处，但我是说，我不知道该怎么比较，但我是说，这跨度太大了。好吧。我是说，你想要准确，特别是在约会的时候，在那个隔间里。我是说。
But, like, I mean, this guy's eyes, like, they, like, literally like a cartoon. They're like, but going, like, he can't, like, believe. that he's about to hook up with Megan Fox. Well, you know what I want to see? Michael Scott on Love is Blind. Oh, my God. Yes, please. You know there's a whole new season of Love is Blind that was just on,
但是，我是说，这个家伙的眼睛，简直像卡通片一样。他们就像，但他不能，他简直不敢相信他要和梅根·福克斯在一起了。好吧，你知道我想看什么吗？迈克尔·斯科特参加《爱情盲选》。哦，天哪。是的，拜托。你知道《爱情盲选》刚播完一整季，
but I haven't watched it yet. I was in Chicago. Should I finally watch it? Should we watch it? I mean, maybe. I don't know. Like, the reunion has aired, and I'm seeing all like the funny recreation videos on Instagram.
但我还没看。我在芝加哥。我终于该看了吗？我们要看吗？我是说，也许吧。我不知道。我是说，重聚篇已经播出了，我在Instagram上看到了所有那些有趣的模仿视频。
I don't know any of the references. I'm having total FOMO, but I don't know. You know, actually, wait, what everyone needs to watch, I can't believe we haven't mentioned this, is the paper, which is starting on NBC tonight. Oh, my God, that is right. Holy crap. Okay, so wait, you guys, in case you didn't know.
我不知道任何梗。我有严重的错失恐惧症，但我不知道。你知道，等等，每个人都需要看的一部剧，我真不敢相信我们还没提过，就是《The Paper》，今晚在NBC开播。哦，天哪，没错。天哪。好吧，等等，伙计们，以防你们不知道。
So Jenna just said it. But the paper's on NBC, like old school NBC, Monday nights at 8.30 Eastern. starting today, right now. Yes, it starts right now. November 10th, depending on when you're listening to this, so you can now watch it each week on NBC. It's Taylor Swift endorsed.
所以珍娜刚说了。但《The Paper》在NBC播出，老派的NBC，东部时间周一晚上8点半。从今天开始，就在现在。是的，现在就开始了。11月10日，取决于你什么时候听这个节目，所以你现在每周都可以在NBC观看。泰勒·斯威夫特代言的。
Yeah, my swifties, Taylor Swift, gave it a shout out twice, twice. Yes. Well, wow. Jenna, we've got lots of stuff to check out. I guess we do. All right, everyone. Well, here's our second drink of Fun Run Part 2. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey we were on The Office together and we're best friends
是啊，我的Swifties，泰勒·斯威夫特，为它打call了两次，两次。是的。哇。珍娜，我们有很多东西要看。我想是的。好吧，各位。这是我们的《Fun Run》第二部分第二杯。我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛，我们一起出演了《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友，
and now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you we're the office ladies on your mark get set go angela it's a fun run Wait, I got a carbload, a bunch of fettuccini three seconds before I run. Good idea. That's not going to turn on you. Give me the creamy carbs seconds before I take off on a huge adventure. Guys, it is Fun Run, Part 2.
现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。各就各位，预备，开始。安吉拉，这是Fun Run。等等，我得补充碳水，在跑步前三秒吃一大堆意大利面。好主意。那不会让你难受吗？给我奶油碳水，就在我开始大冒险前几秒。伙计们，这是《Fun Run》第二部分。
This is the very beginning of season 4, written by Greg Daniels, directed by Greg Daniels. Let me hitch up with a summary. Last week, Michael hit Meredith with his... his car breaking her pelvis. And we discovered, though, that Meredith's trip to the hospital may have saved her life since it was revealed she had possibly been exposed to rabies and has now received a vaccine. We also found out that Sprinkles died on Dwight's watch. On Dwight's watch? Well, this week, this week, Michael organizes a fun run to raise money for rabies. in honor of Meredith, and we find out what really happened to sprinkles.
这是第四季的开头，由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。让我来总结一下。上周，迈克尔用他的车撞了梅雷迪思，撞断了她的骨盆。但我们发现，梅雷迪思去医院可能救了她的命，因为据透露她可能接触过狂犬病，现在已经接种了疫苗。我们还发现Sprinkles是在德怀特的看管下死去的。在德怀特的看管下？好吧，这周，这周，迈克尔组织了一场Fun Run来为狂犬病筹款，以纪念梅雷迪思，我们还会发现Sprinkles到底发生了什么。
Do you see what I'm wearing in honor of this episode? You're wearing your office lady's sprinkles sweatshirt. I am wearing my sprinkles sweatshirt. Well, lady, I did not wear anything in honor of sprinkles today. Well, you know what? That tracks for Pam in this episode because she helps, like Angela, let's see, zero amount. Zero amount. Sorry.
你看到我为了纪念这一集穿了什么吗？你穿着你的《办公室女士》Sprinkles卫衣。我穿着我的Sprinkles卫衣。好吧，亲爱的，我今天没穿任何纪念Sprinkles的东西。好吧，你知道吗？这很符合帕姆在这一集的表现，因为她帮忙，安吉拉，让我们看看，零贡献。零贡献。抱歉。
That's okay. She's distracted. because in this episode, it's also going to be revealed that Jim and Pam are dating. Listen, one thing I thought of when I watched this episode was, wow, happy Pam is a sassy Pam. She gives zero Fs about what's going on around her. She's a totally different person. Happy SaaS. Happy SaaS.
没关系。她分心了。因为在这一集里，还会揭露吉姆和帕姆在约会。听着，我看这一集时想到的第一件事就是，哇，快乐的帕姆是个俏皮的帕姆。她完全不在乎周围发生了什么。她完全变了一个人。快乐的俏皮。快乐的俏皮。
Happy Sam Sass. Happy Pam Sass. Well, let's get into these fast facts. Fast fact number one. You know, this episode is technically the. second part of the episode that we broke down last week, right? Because these episodes were an hour long. But if you notice, I feel like these episodes really stand on their own. They kind of both had their own little plots, right? For sure. Well, I talked to Greg about that and he told
快乐的帕姆俏皮。快乐的帕姆俏皮。好吧，让我们进入这些快讯。快讯第一条。你知道，这一集技术上是我们上周解析的那一集的第二部分，对吧？因为这些剧集是一个小时长的。但如果你注意到了，我觉得这些剧集确实可以独立存在。它们都有各自的小情节，对吧？确实。好吧，我和格雷格聊过这个，他告诉我
me that Kevin Riley requested four hour long episodes to kick off season four. So the first four episodes of this season are all an hour long. Kevin loved our show, but was there any other reason besides he was like, I want more office? I think it was just that would be a big announcement in the press, the return of the office, four hour long episodes. Maybe also they didn't have something for the other time slot. So we were filling two time slots. I'm speculating. I don't know. I like your speculating. face and tone. Because my husband does this sometimes when he wants to let the kids down easy. Like it's like, hey guys, so about those pumpkins that we were going to get? They exploded from the heat, but yeah. Well, I was excited that we got these big supersized episodes. It meant that for the supporting cast, some of our storylines would definitely stay in. And that was exciting. Yes. Well, Greg, also told me that Kevin Riley told him they're only going to run in this hour-long length once
凯文·赖利要求四集一小时长的剧集来开启第四季。所以这一季的前四集都是一小时长的。凯文喜欢我们的剧，但除了他想要更多《办公室》之外，还有其他原因吗？我想这只是因为在媒体上会是一个大新闻，《办公室》回归，四集一小时长的剧集。也许是因为他们没有其他时段的节目。所以我们填补了两个时段。我是在推测。我不知道。我喜欢你推测时的表情和语气。因为我丈夫有时想让孩子们容易接受坏消息时也会这样。就像，嘿，伙计们，关于我们要买的那些南瓜？它们因为高温爆炸了，但，是的。好吧，我很高兴我们有了这些超大号的剧集。这意味着对于配角来说，我们的一些故事情节肯定会保留下来。这很令人兴奋。是的。好吧，格雷格也告诉我，凯文·赖利告诉他，它们只会以这种一小时的长度播出一次
at the beginning of the season. Then we're going to have to rerun them later as half-hours. And that's really why they stand alone. Greg said it was a challenge because he had to wrap up the first episode in a way that would make it satisfying for a future viewer to watch it in a half-hour form, but he couldn't wrap it up too much for the people who were watching it as a one-hour episode. He said it was kind of a writing challenge. That sounds like a challenge. I think he did it, though. I think he crushed it. Greg Daniels, you crushed it. Bass fact number two lady is a wardrobe breakdown with Carrie Bennett. I love me some Carrie Bennett. Let's hear it. We got so much mail about the wardrobe in this episode, which makes sense because we're
在季初。然后我们以后必须把它们重播为半小时的。这就是为什么它们能独立存在。格雷格说这是一个挑战，因为他必须以一种让未来的观众在半小时形式下观看时感到满意的方式结束第一集，但他不能为那些看一小时剧集的观众结束得太多。他说这是一种写作挑战。听起来确实是个挑战。但我认为他做到了。我认为他完成得非常出色。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，你太棒了。快讯第二条，亲爱的，是与凯莉·贝内特的服装解析。我喜欢凯莉·贝内特。让我们听听。我们收到了很多关于这一集服装的邮件，这很合理，因为我们
seeing everybody out of their office attire, which Carrie said was always a challenge because she had created these office uniforms for people. So anytime we wore our quote-unquote street clothes, she was like, who are these people in their street clothes? Here's some of the mail we got. Alicia W. and Amanda Mitchenfelder said, did you get to keep your shirts from Fun Run? And Emily Thomas wants to know, did you get to keep a support? the rabid wristband. Yeah, I kept both. I kept my shirt and I kept my wristband. I had my wristband for a long time. It's probably somewhere in my scrapbook bin. My t-shirt, I did not keep. Carrie kept it in case we ever needed Angela Martin to wear it again because we weren't sure
看到每个人都脱下了办公室装束，凯莉说这总是一个挑战，因为她为每个人创造了这些办公室制服。所以每当我们穿所谓的“便装”时，她就会想，这些穿便装的人是谁？这是我们收到的一些邮件。艾丽西亚·W和阿曼达·米琴费尔德说，你们能保留《Fun Run》的衬衫吗？艾米丽·托马斯想知道，你们能保留那个狂犬病腕带吗？是的，我都留着。我留下了我的衬衫和腕带。我留了很久。它可能在我的剪贴簿盒子里。我的T恤，我没留。凯莉留着它，以防我们需要安吉拉·马丁再穿一次，因为我们不确定
how long this morning process was going to go, you know? Well, we should remind people, Angela, you did not wear one of the famous blue Fun Run T-shirts. You wore a shirt with a picture of sprinkles on it. Yeah. Because people wrote in about this shirt, too, Angela. Molly C. And Isaiah Johnson asked, where did Angela's sprinkle shirt come from? And did you get to keep it?
这个哀悼过程会持续多久，你知道吗？好吧，我们应该提醒大家，安吉拉，你没有穿那件著名的蓝色《Fun Run》T恤。你穿了一件印有Sprinkles照片的衬衫。是的。因为人们也写信问这件衬衫的事，安吉拉。莫莉·C和以赛亚·约翰逊问，安吉拉的Sprinkles衬衫是从哪来的？你留着它了吗？
You said you did not keep it. I did not keep it. And Carrie made that shirt. She had that shirt made. And also when I had my wardrobe fitting for this, Carrie and I talked. And Angela would not be in shorts. She would not wear shorts.
你说你没留。我没留。凯莉制作了那件衬衫。她让人做了那件衬衫。而且当我进行服装试穿时，凯莉和我聊过。安吉拉不会穿短裤。她不会穿短裤。
So that's why I have sort of those little crop pants. And then at first they had kids for me. And I was like, I can't run in kids. And I have to actually run. So I need an actual sneaker. There you go. There you go. Well, Carrie told me about those blue shirts, the famous blue shirts with all the writing on them.
所以这就是为什么我穿了那种小七分裤。起初他们给我准备了短裤。我说，我不能穿短裤跑步。而且我必须真的跑。所以我需要一双真正的运动鞋。就是这样。就是这样。好吧，凯莉告诉了我关于那些蓝色衬衫的事，那些印着所有文字的著名蓝色衬衫。
So she designed those. We made them ourselves. She said that she just tried to imagine Michael getting on the phone and ordering those t-shirts with the ridiculously long name and insisting that all the words be on the shirt, which I think is a very funny way to approach that design. I mean, I thought it was perfect. And honestly, while we're talking about the shirt, what the heck kind of budget did they have for this? Not only did they have bracelets and those t-shirts, they had flyers and banners, they had a giant Meredith photo poster and a giant check. What was their budget? I mean, we're going to see when we get to that scene in the conference room that we spend
所以她设计了那些。我们自己制作的。她说她只是试着想象迈克尔打电话订购那些印着荒谬长名字的T恤，并坚持要把所有字都印在衬衫上，我觉得这是一种非常有趣的构思方式。我是说，我觉得这很完美。老实说，当我们谈论衬衫时，他们到底有多少预算？他们不仅有手环和那些T恤，还有传单和横幅，他们有一张巨大的梅雷迪思照片海报和一张巨额支票。他们的预算是多少？我是说，当我们看到会议室的那一幕时，我们会发现我们花
quite a bit of our donation money just throwing the fun run. Carrie also told me that she chose the color blue for the shirts because everybody had to wear it and blue looks good on everyone. She said she always applies the same logic for photos. shoots and promo shoots. Blue just looks best. That's right. Well, let's talk about Dwight fan question from Ella Lewis. Why isn't Dwight wearing a Fun Run shirt? I feel like he would have been the most likely to support Michael's ideas, yet he's wearing a Shrut Farm shirt instead. I think it makes perfect sense that he would self-advertise. I agree with Ella. I was surprised that Dwight would not
了相当一部分捐款来举办Fun Run。凯莉还告诉我，她选择蓝色作为衬衫颜色，因为每个人都必须穿，而且蓝色穿在每个人身上都好看。她说她总是把同样的逻辑应用到照片拍摄和宣传拍摄中。蓝色就是最好看。没错。好吧，让我们谈谈德怀特，来自埃拉·刘易斯的粉丝提问。为什么德怀特没穿《Fun Run》衬衫？我觉得他最有可能支持迈克尔的想法，但他却穿了一件Shrut农场的衬衫。我觉得他自我宣传很有道理。我同意埃拉的看法。我很惊讶德怀特竟然没有
just champion Michael the way he does. Carrie told me that she made this shirt. She's She literally just used a standard stencil and she spray painted it in that parking lot right before we started shooting. But after the episode aired, NBC Marketing Department got so many requests for that shirt that they called her and asked her for her art files so that they could mass produce it and sell it. And Carrie was like, don't have an art file. Have a spray painting thing that I made in the parking lot. If you want to come get my spray paint stencil. Yeah. She was like, okay. All right. Well, our final question about the clothing comes from Ian MP and Marina Blank. They're asking, is Michael wearing women's shorts for Fun Run? Oh, man. They're definitely some kind of like biker short with like the little windbreaker short over it.
像他平时那样支持迈克尔。凯莉告诉我，她制作了这件衬衫。她字面上只是用了一个标准模板，在我们要开始拍摄前就在停车场喷漆了。但在剧集播出后，NBC营销部门收到了很多关于那件衬衫的请求，他们打电话给她，向她要艺术文件，以便他们可以批量生产并销售。凯莉说，没有艺术文件。我有一个在停车场做的喷漆模板。如果你想来拿我的喷漆模板。是的。她说，好吧。好吧，关于服装的最后一个问题来自伊恩·MP和玛丽娜·布兰克。他们问，迈克尔在《Fun Run》里穿的是女式短裤吗？哦，天哪。它们绝对是某种骑行短裤，外面套着那种防风短裤。
Yeah. Carrie says no. They were not women's shorts. She said, the thing with Steve was that he's actually really fit. And Angela, you and I know this. He was really, really into fitness. Well, he got into great shape. We've talked about that for 40-year-old Virgin. And then he has just made that part of his lifestyle. And I think in this episode, when he gets in his shorts and his T-shirt, you can see how fit he is. There's no hiding how fit he is. He has like 0% body fat. And it's very clear. Carrie said it was a really a challenge to make him look like Michael anytime he was out of his
是的。凯莉说不。那不是女式短裤。她说，史蒂夫的问题在于他其实真的很健壮。安吉拉，你和我都知道这一点。他真的很热衷于健身。好吧，他练就了很好的身材。我们聊过《四十岁的老处男》。然后他把这变成了他生活方式的一部分。我觉得在这一集中，当他穿上短裤和T恤时，你可以看到他有多健壮。他有多健壮是藏不住的。他几乎没有体脂。这很明显。凯莉说，每当他脱下他那种
sort of frumpy Michael suit because he just was in such great shape. She said it was just kind of difficult. So there you go. Yeah. That is a costume breakdown. I like it.
邋遢的迈克尔西装时，让他看起来像迈克尔真的是个挑战，因为他身材太好了。她说这有点困难。所以就是这样。是的。这就是服装解析。我喜欢。
I like it. All right. Fast fact number three, as you know in this episode, Jim and Pam do not run. A lot of people run. But Jim and Pam do not. They walk. They go to an estate sale. Jim and Pam don't run. And Oscar and Stanley and Creed take a cab. But Jim and Pam do not run. They walk in the back. They hold hands. Well, there was a reason for this. I know. The reason for this is because in May of 2007, we shot this in August. In May, I fell down a set of stairs in New York. In New York.
我喜欢。好吧，快讯第三条，如你所知，在这一集中，吉姆和帕姆没有跑。很多人跑了。但吉姆和帕姆没有。他们走路。他们去参加了一场遗产拍卖会。吉姆和帕姆没有跑。奥斯卡、斯坦利和克里德坐了出租车。但吉姆和帕姆没有跑。他们在后面走。他们牵着手。好吧，这有一个原因。我知道。原因是因为在2007年5月，我们在8月拍摄了这一集。在5月，我在纽约摔下了一组楼梯。在纽约
York City, and I fractured four bones in my back, and I was not allowed to run. So the writers had to write a reason for me to only walk through this episode. That was such a scary night. I was with you. I know you were. That was so scary. Yeah. So here's what happened. It was May, and we were in New York, and we were promoting the office. We were promoting the season finale. and they threw this big party, in quotes, party. It was a work event at this club called Buda Khan. Yeah, it was our job to kind of hobnob with advertisers and stuff. We were at work, but it was a fancy work.
市，我的背部骨折了四处，我不被允许跑步。所以编剧们必须写一个理由让我只能在这一集中走路。那是一个非常可怕的夜晚。我和你在一起。我知道你在。那太可怕了。是的。所以发生了什么。那是5月，我们在纽约，我们在宣传《办公室》。我们在宣传季终集。他们举办了这个盛大的派对，引号里的派对。这是一个在名为Buda Khan的俱乐部举办的工作活动。是的，我们的工作是和广告商之类的社交。我们在工作，但那是高级的工作。
Yes. So we're all dressed up and this club is two floors. So you enter on the upper floor. They had this little bar with drinks and they were serving these like pineappley, daquery things. and it was sweet, and I was like, this seems great. So I grabbed one, but then to get to kind of the main part of the event, you had to go down this long set of stairs that were marble. And they were steep, you guys. They had a really deep pitch to them.
是的。所以我们都盛装打扮，这个俱乐部有两层。所以你从上层进入。他们有一个小酒吧，有饮料，他们供应那种像菠萝代基里的东西。而且很甜，我想，这看起来不错。所以我拿了一杯，但要到达活动的主要部分，你必须走下一组很长的楼梯，是大理石的。而且它们很陡，伙计们。它们的坡度非常深。
Yeah, they're still there. This club is still there. So I'm walking down these stairs. I've basically just arrived. I've taken one sip of my little daughery, and something happens. My foot slips out from underneath me, and I go. crashing down on the edge of these stairs hard. To add insult to injury, I also threw my drink in my own face.
是的，它们还在那里。这个俱乐部还在那里。所以我走下这些楼梯。我基本上刚到。我喝了一口我的小代基里，然后发生了什么。我的脚从下面滑了出去，我重重地摔在这些楼梯的边缘。雪上加霜的是，我还把饮料泼在了自己脸上。
So that was fun. So I'm sitting on the ground. I'm half covered in daquery. And I immediately start to feel like I'm going to vomit or everything gets dizzy. And I remember this bouncer comes over and picked me up. And he was treating me like I was like a booze. boozy, drunken Hollywood Starlet. Like, he was in no way regarding me with much care.
所以那很有趣。所以我坐在地上。我身上沾了一半代基里。我立刻开始觉得我要呕吐，或者一切都变得头晕。我记得这个保镖走过来把我扶起来。他对待我好像我是那种喝醉了的酒鬼好莱坞小明星。他一点也没表现出关心。
It was like, get her out of there. Get the booze her out. And I was like, I'm not, I don't, but I was all disoriented, you know. So I remember they took me back to the storeroom, Angela, and you were there. And I told you I didn't feel good. And I remember you lifted up the back of my shirt. And you said, call an ambulance. Well, I was behind you on that staircase, and I saw you go down. It happened in slow motion.
就像，把她弄出去。把那个酒鬼弄出去。我说，我不是，我不，但我当时很迷茫，你知道。所以我记得他们把我带回了储藏室，安吉拉，你在那里。我告诉你我不舒服。我记得你掀起了我的衬衫后背。你说，叫救护车。好吧，我在那楼梯上你后面，我看到你摔下去了。一切都像慢动作。
Someone had spilt their drink or something on those stairs, and they were marble, and they were slick. And you had these wedge shoes on. You turned your ankle, and you went down so hard. And you know, when you're the person watching something happen, how you're like, nah, like, I didn't know how to stop it. It was all in motion. And, yeah, I'll never forget that night because you're back. was, it looked bad and, yeah, I was scared. Well, I don't remember much else after that. I don't remember the ambulance ride, but I know you were with me, Ange. And I remember going in and out at the hospital, and you were by my side the whole time,
有人把饮料洒在了楼梯上，它们是大理石的，很滑。你穿着坡跟鞋。你扭伤了脚踝，摔得很重。你知道，当你是一个看着事情发生的人时，你会想，不，我不知道怎么阻止它。一切都在进行中。而且，是的，我永远不会忘记那个夜晚，因为你的背部，看起来很糟糕，是的，我很害怕。好吧，在那之后我不记得太多了。我不记得救护车之旅，但我知道你和我在一起，安吉。我记得在医院里进进出出，你一直在我身边，
lady. I know. You were there. And I remember they x-rayed me. I remember you told me the guy in the bed next to me was handcuffed to his bed? There was a guy in a chair next to your bed. brought him in. He was real surly, and they handcuffed him to the chair. And I shut the little curtain around your bed. Oh, dear. And also, I was staying with you and I was really adamant about it.
亲爱的。我知道。你在那里。我记得他们给我拍了X光片。我记得你告诉我我隔壁床的家伙被铐在床上了？你床边的一把椅子上有一个家伙。他们把他带进来了。他真的很粗鲁，他们把他铐在椅子上。我拉上了你床周围的小帘子。哦，天哪。而且，我一直陪着你，我对此非常坚持。
You know, I was like, she has no family here. I am not like going anywhere. She's in an emergency room in a city that's not her own. She has no family. And you are stuck with me, buddy. So they they didn't mess with me and I stayed with you till four in the morning we got you a hospital room and we knew more details then and once we got you set up in your room I went I was supposed to be on the today show that morning with Rain Wilson we were supposed to be interviewed for the office and they had a whole piece about Dwight and Angela and I asked NBC you know I was like I'm supposed to be on the air in an hour but I'm in a hospital room with my friend I can't I can't be there. And they said, don't worry. We'll let the Today Show know. So years later, I'm at the White House Correspondence dinner. I'm sitting at the NBC Today Show table. And we talk about, we're just talking about, oh, when was the last time we saw you? And they were like, you were supposed to do the Today Show with Rain Wilson. You were a no show. And I was like, what? I wasn't a no show. I was with Jenna in a hospital. Didn't they tell you that?
你知道，我说，她在这里没有家人。我哪儿也不去。她在一家不是她所在城市的急诊室。她没有家人。你被我缠住了，伙计。所以他们没敢惹我，我一直陪你到凌晨四点。我们给你弄了一个病房，那时我们知道了更多细节，一旦把你安顿在房间里，我就去了，我本该那天早上和雷恩·威尔逊一起上《今日秀》。我们本该接受《办公室》的采访，他们有一个关于德怀特和安吉拉的专题，我告诉NBC，你知道，我说我本该在一小时后上节目，但我正和我的朋友在病房里，我不能，我不能去。他们说，别担心。我们会通知《今日秀》。所以多年后，我在白宫记者晚宴上。我坐在NBC《今日秀》的桌子旁。我们谈论，我们只是在谈论，哦，我们上次见到你是什么时候？他们说，你本该和雷恩·威尔逊一起上《今日秀》。你没来。我说，什么？我不是没来。我和珍娜在医院。他们没告诉你吗？
They never told them. They never told them why you didn't show up. They just thought you were like a flaky actress. This night branded me in this bouncer's eyes as some boozed up actress. And then the Today Show the next day thought you were a flake. And we were like, no, tragedy. Tragedy happened. Yeah.
他们从来没告诉他们。他们从来没告诉他们你为什么没出现。他们只是以为你是个不靠谱的演员。那个夜晚在那个保镖眼里给我贴上了酒鬼演员的标签。然后第二天《今日秀》以为你是个不靠谱的人。我们说，不，悲剧。悲剧发生了。是的。
And I've done the Today Show now since, but I was like, how many years did they just think I didn't show up? Oh my gosh. Well, you know, I'll never forget the doctor coming in, and he said, the good news is you're going to walk again. Oh, my God. And I was like, that's the good. I mean, that is good news, but that sounds like there's a lot of bad news coming. So as it turns out, I had fractured four of the transverse vertebrae in my back. If you're going to have a back injury, I guess this is the best one, because they heal on their own, similar to a broken.
从那以后我上过《今日秀》，但我当时想，他们到底以为我没出现多少年？哦，天哪。好吧，你知道，我永远不会忘记医生走进来，他说，好消息是你还能走路。哦，天哪。我说，那是好消息。我是说，那确实是好消息，但这听起来后面还有很多坏消息。结果证明，我的背部有四节横突椎骨骨折了。如果你非要背部受伤，我想这是最好的情况，因为它们会自行愈合，类似于骨折。
and rib, and motion is the best thing for you. So even though walking and moving was really difficult for me, I was encouraged to do it. Here's a crazy twist to the story. You know, NBC had put us up at the Ritz Carlton for these two days that we were going to do press. They had a deal with the hotel and the entire cast was put up at the Ritz Carlton. And remember, Lady, we asked for adjoining rooms. And we were so excited. Talk about coming. country mouse come to town. We're at the Ritz facing Central Park. Two whole nights. We were so excited. Well, I couldn't go home. I couldn't leave. So NBC had to pay for me to live at the Ritz Carlton for two weeks. And guess what? For the first week, I was with you the whole time.
肋骨，运动是对你最好的事情。所以即使走路和移动对我来说非常困难，我还是被鼓励去做。这里有一个故事的疯狂转折。你知道，NBC把我们安排在丽思卡尔顿酒店住两天，我们要进行宣传。他们和酒店有协议，整个剧组都住在丽思卡尔顿。还记得吗，亲爱的，我们要求连通房。我们太兴奋了。谈谈乡下老鼠进城。我们住在丽思卡尔顿，面对中央公园。整整两个晚上。我们太兴奋了。好吧，我不能回家。我不能离开。所以NBC不得不付钱让我住在丽思卡尔顿两周。你猜怎么着？第一周，我一直和你在一起。
I know. You didn't leave my side. I didn't leave your side because you had family. on the way, but, you know, they needed a few days to get there. And so I was there. And I just remember that time. And, you know, I think every friendship has these milestone moments that you're forever bonded by. And we've certainly had a few. And best friends listening to this out there, you know those moments. This was one of those moments when you're helping your friend get on the toilet. Yep. And Jenna, you did this for me. After my C-section, you help me. Like, I, remember this. These were, this was one of those BFF moments. We have both been with the other while one has had a catheter. Yeah. Do you need your friend to step out while I give you this
我知道。你没离开我身边。我没离开你身边，因为你有家人。在路上，但，你知道，他们需要几天才能到。所以我一直在那儿。我只记得那段时间。而且，你知道，我觉得每段友谊都有这些里程碑式的时刻，你们因此永远联系在一起。我们当然有过几次。听这个节目的好朋友们，你们知道那些时刻。这是其中一个时刻，当你帮助你的朋友上厕所时。是的。珍娜，你为我做了这个。在我剖腹产后，你帮我。像，我，记得这个。这些是，这是那些BFF时刻之一。我们俩都在对方插导尿管的时候陪着对方。是的。你需要你的朋友出去，让我给你插这个
catheter? Nah, she can stay. No, I'd actually prefer to hold her hand, please. Yeah. I'd like someone here with me. Yeah. So anybody out there, if you're wondering why Angela and I are best friends and We'll be best friends forever. Friends who catheter together stay together, all right? Oh, man. My final piece of this story is simply that I couldn't shower for several days and my hair was so smelly. I'm sorry you had to live with that, Ange. That pineapple, it really turned real gross.
导尿管吗？不，她可以留下。不，我其实更希望握着她的手，拜托。是的。我希望有人在这里陪我。是的。所以任何在那边的人，如果你想知道为什么安吉拉和我最好的朋友，我们将永远是最好的朋友。一起插导尿管的朋友会永远在一起，好吗？哦，天哪。我这个故事的最后一部分很简单，我好几天没法洗澡，我的头发太臭了。很抱歉你不得不忍受那个，安吉。那个菠萝味，真的变得很恶心。
And I did wet a wash rag and try to dampen your hair with the wash rag. Yeah, you did. You did. Guys, that's why Pam doesn't run in this episode. I was healed, but I don't think at this point I was driving myself yet and I wasn't allowed to run. Your doctor had you on a very specific sort of recovery plan because you do not mess with the back. You don't mess around. But I'm fully healed now. No problems. No residual problems. Well, I loved the storyline for Jim and Pam. I thought it made it just really sweet.
我确实弄湿了一块洗脸巾，试着用洗脸巾弄湿你的头发。是的，你做了。你做了。伙计们，这就是为什么帕姆在这一集中不跑步。我痊愈了，但我觉得那时我还没法自己开车，而且我不被允许跑步。你的医生为你制定了一个非常具体的康复计划，因为你不能拿背部开玩笑。你不能乱来。但我现在完全痊愈了。没有问题。没有后遗症。好吧，我喜欢吉姆和帕姆的故事情节。我觉得这让它变得非常甜蜜。
Like, they were just going to hang out. They weren't going to participate. And then they had this sort of lovely walk and they got to hold hands. And I thought it worked out great. It worked. It worked. Well, guys, thanks for listening to us. Go down that memory lane.
就像，他们只是要去闲逛。他们不打算参加。然后他们有了这种可爱的散步，他们可以牵手。我觉得这效果很好。它奏效了。它奏效了。好吧，伙计们，感谢你们听我们讲述。走下那条记忆之路。
We'll take a break and we'll be back to really dive into this episode. Okay, we are back. This episode opens with Pam answering the phone. Michael Scott's Dunder Mifflin, Scranton, Meredith Palmer, Memorial, Celebrity, Rabies Awareness, Fun Run Race for the Cure. But it's, you know, it's the pro-am race for the cure. My favorite thing about that whole moment was how you delivered. They hung up. It's so good.
我们要休息一下，然后回来深入探讨这一集。好吧，我们回来了。这一集以帕姆接电话开始。迈克尔·斯科特的邓德·米夫林，斯克兰顿，梅雷迪思·帕尔默，纪念，名人，狂犬病意识，Fun Run治愈赛。但它是，你知道，是治愈赛的职业业余配对赛。关于那一刻我最喜欢的是你说话的方式。他们挂断了。太棒了。
It's so good. Well, we got some fan questions about this from Gabriel B, Frank F, Calos D, Alberto R, and Camille Y. Jenna, did you have to memorize that long title for the Fun Run Race for the Cure? Or did you look at a piece of paper every time you said it? No, you guys, I had to memorize that. But I did have it sitting on a piece of paper in front of me. Like, I would look at it intensely because that is a mouthful. That is a lot to have to say.
太棒了。好吧，我们收到了一些关于这个的粉丝提问，来自加布里埃尔·B，弗兰克·F，卡洛斯·D，阿尔贝托·R和卡米尔·Y。珍娜，你必须背下那个Fun Run治愈赛的长标题吗？还是你每次说的时候都看一张纸？不，伙计们，我必须背下来。但我确实把它放在我面前的一张纸上。就像，我会专注地看着它，因为那太拗口了。那要说的话太多了。
Yeah. But I did memorize it for that scene. And it's a mouthful that doesn't make sense. Like for me, I can memorize something if it makes sense. My brain will piece it together for me. But if it's just like a list, you have to work at it. Yeah, that is more difficult for sure. Like, there's no way I could have ever been one of those doctors on ER or whatever, like on Grays Anatomy where they're running down the hallway and they got someone on the stretcher and they're like, we need three BPUs and get the suture sew it up.
是的。但我确实为那个场景背下来了。而且这是一个说不通的拗口句子。对我来说，如果它有意义，我可以背下东西。我的大脑会为我拼凑起来。但如果它只是一个列表，你必须努力去记。是的，那肯定更难。我是说，我永远不可能成为《急诊室的故事》或者《实习医生格蕾》里那种医生，他们在走廊里跑，担架上有人，他们说，我们需要三个BPU，缝合它，缝好它。
I think that all the time when I watch those shows, all the time. I think like they're just yelling out jargon. They have no idea what they're saying. Yes. Yeah. Well, then Michael has an amazing talking head that I really love, where he lets us know that a woman should not have to be hit by a car to learn that she has rapies. But here we are.
我看那些剧时总是这么想，总是。我想他们只是在喊行话。他们根本不知道自己在说什么。是的。是的。好吧，然后迈克尔有一个我真的很喜欢的精彩采访片段，他让我们知道，一个女人不应该为了知道自己有狂犬病而被车撞。但我们还是发生了。
Well, you know what, Michael is there fighting for women once again. Yes, exactly. Well, then we go out into the bullpen. We're panning around. People are, I guess, on the phone's kind of phone banking, trying to get donations for this cause. He has the whole office doing this. It's unbelievable that any of us had a job after this day. And I love that he walked up and said, hi, Stankley.
好吧，你知道吗，迈克尔再次在那里为女性而战。是的，没错。好吧，然后我们走到办公区。我们环顾四周。人们，我想，在电话上进行电话筹款，试图为这个事业筹集捐款。他让整个办公室都在做这个。真不敢相信我们在这一天之后还有工作。我喜欢他走过去说，嗨，斯坦利。
Like, when is Michael going to learn? You can't do bits with Stanley. Stanley doesn't want your bits. He doesn't. Stanley is a bit-free person. Yeah, don't bring your bits to Stanley. Well, Phyllis is hard at work on the rabies quilt. She holds it up.
就像，迈克尔什么时候才能学乖？你不能和斯坦利开玩笑。斯坦利不想要你的玩笑。他不想。斯坦利是一个没有玩笑的人。是的，别把你的玩笑带给斯坦利。好吧，菲利斯正在努力制作狂犬病拼布被。她把它举起来。
How many quilts does this company make? I mean, I felt like this was a callback to the Depression quilt from safety training. Any wonder, Dwight was like, should we do a depression quilt? And Michael's like, no, no time to sew the quilt. Because clearly it's a thing. It's a thing. Put Phyllis on it. Well, we had a fan question from Mary Halsey.
这家公司到底做了多少拼布被？我是说，我觉得这是对安全培训中抑郁拼布被的回应。难怪，德怀特说，我们应该做一个抑郁拼布被吗？迈克尔说，不，没时间缝拼布被了。因为显然这是一回事。这是一回事。让菲利斯去做吧。好吧，我们有一个来自玛丽·哈尔西的粉丝提问。
Who made the rabies quilt? Well, guys, it was Phil Shea. I mean, he didn't personally make it, but he had to get someone to make those squares. And if you want to buy it, there is a full-size version of the quilt online. Just Google it. Get out. Get out. Rabies quilt the office.
谁制作了狂犬病拼布被？好吧，伙计们，是菲尔·谢。我是说，他没有亲自制作，但他必须找人制作那些方块。如果你想买它，网上有一个全尺寸版本的拼布被。去谷歌搜一下。走开。走开。狂犬病拼布被 办公室。
People are making them. You can buy them. I have going to Google that. I want to see it. You know, my mom's a quilter, you know? Yes. Angela, in my notes for today, I literally wrote, Angela, your mom quilts. I have several pieces of your mom's quilting.
人们正在制作它们。你可以买到。我打算去谷歌搜一下。我想看看。你知道，我妈妈是个拼布被制作者，你知道吗？是的。安吉拉，在今天的笔记里，我字面上写了，安吉拉，你妈妈做拼布被。我有几件你妈妈做的拼布被。
My mom is old school type of quilter where, you know, no machine. She cuts out all the pieces and then she like makes her pattern. She'll use like one of the bedrooms in the house. And then she soes that all by hand. And she'll do the backing sometimes, you know, with the machine. But she actually purchased in Pennsylvania years and years ago from an Amish family, a wooden quilt rack. And every peg, everything is wooden. There's no metal screws or anything.
我妈妈是老派的拼布爱好者，你知道的，不用缝纫机。她把所有的布料都剪裁好，然后自己设计图案。她会占用家里的一间卧室，然后全手工缝制。有时候她会用缝纫机做背衬，但她多年前在宾夕法尼亚州从一个阿米什家庭买了一个木制的拼布架。每一个销钉，所有东西都是木制的，没有金属螺丝之类的东西。
And she puts her quilt top on there and quilts. And I feel like every single one is a piece of art. Since we're talking about quilting, I want to bring up this artist that I love, Bisa Butler. She makes these huge life-size quilted portraits that I'm slightly obsessed with. Go to her Instagram page. It's at Bisa Butler. They look like painting. but they're not.
她把拼布面料放在上面进行缝制。我觉得每一件作品都是艺术品。既然我们在谈论拼布，我想提一下我非常喜欢的艺术家比萨·巴特勒（Bisa Butler）。她制作这些巨大的真人大小的拼布肖像画，我有点着迷。去她的Instagram页面看看，账号是Bisa Butler。它们看起来像油画，但其实不是。
I'm going to look at it right now. Okay, look at it. Oh, my gosh. They're beautiful. Yeah, I just love her work, lady. I love it. I can't wait to see it in person one day. It's beautiful.
我现在就去看看。好的，看吧。天哪，它们太美了。是的，我就是喜欢她的作品，亲爱的。我太喜欢了。我真希望能有一天亲眼看到它们。太美了。
It's art. It's gorgeous. And she was featured in the New York Times as well. She had this. I mean, she's all over the place. She's a big deal. But check it out. Beza Butler on Instagram.
这是艺术，太华丽了。她还被《纽约时报》报道过。我的意思是，她到处都是，她是个大人物。一定要去看看，Instagram上的Bisa Butler。
Well, you know, we're about to move on to an Andy talking head here about nipple chafing. But did you notice Andy is now sitting at Karen's desk? I did. And also, we didn't mention this last week, but when Karen cleared out, did she take the company phone and the computer? Like, everything was gone. Everything. It was all gone.
嗯，你知道，我们马上要转到安迪关于乳头磨损的访谈片段了。但你注意到安迪现在坐在凯伦的办公桌前了吗？我注意到了。而且，我们上周没提过，凯伦搬走的时候，她带走了公司电话和电脑吗？就像，所有东西都不见了。所有东西，全都没了。
Yeah. Well, we had a fan question about Andy's nipple chafing from Lindsay L. Who said, who came up with the nipple chafing idea. was it based off of a personal experience? Well, Greg told me that this was an idea from Justin Spitzer, so I asked him about it, and he said, yes, this was his idea, and that he had once handed out waters and blankets to runners who were finishing the Chicago Marathon, and he could not believe how many men were crossing the finish line with blotches of blood on their shirts over their nipples from nipple chafing.
是的。嗯，我们收到了一个关于安迪乳头磨损的粉丝提问，来自林赛·L（Lindsay L）。她问，是谁想出了乳头磨损这个点子？是基于个人经历吗？嗯，格雷格告诉我这是贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）的主意，所以我问了他，他说是的，这确实是他的主意。他曾经在芝加哥马拉松终点给跑者发水和毯子，他简直不敢相信有多少男人冲过终点线时，衬衫上因为乳头磨损而沾着血迹。
He said it sort of, it shocked him and haunted him, and he had been obsessed with it ever since, and he was finally able to write it into an episode. So I think this was very healing for him. It's a real. He was able to take this experience and turn it into art. Well, it's a real thing. And of course, I looked it up. Jenna, it's also called joggers nipple. Oh.
他说这让他感到震惊，甚至困扰着他，从那以后他就一直对此念念不忘，最后终于把它写进了一集剧本里。所以我认为这对他是种治愈。这真的是……他能够把这段经历转化为艺术。嗯，这确实是真实存在的事情。当然，我查了一下，珍娜，这也被称为“慢跑者乳头”。哦。
I had no idea. It was such a thing. And it's more common in the winter because nipples are erect then. Uh-huh. But there's many ways to prevent it. And one of them is sort of like covering them like this. And there are all kinds of companies that make these. And now there's nipple covers for women, like when you don't want your nipples to show in clothing.
我完全不知道这竟然是个普遍现象。而且在冬天更常见，因为那时候乳头会勃起。嗯哼。但有很多方法可以预防。其中一种就是像这样遮住它们。有很多公司生产这种产品。现在还有女性用的乳贴，比如当你不想让乳头在衣服下显露出来的时候。
You know, we've had wardrobe fittings where sometimes they're like, oh, we might need to put something there. But there's a whole other industry for men. And, you know, I love a good name. for businesses. I love it. So we've got a few that I found were nip-ease, Mr. Nip, nip strips. Wow. Well, I imagine, I guess, because men have hairier chest.
你知道，我们试装的时候，有时他们会说，哦，我们可能需要在那里放点东西。但男性也有一个完整的产业。而且，你知道，我喜欢商业中那些好听的名字。我太喜欢了。所以我发现了一些，比如Nip-ease，Mr. Nip，Nip strips。哇。嗯，我想，大概是因为男人的胸毛比较多吧。
Like, what I noticed when Ed was, like, covering his nipples was, I just kept thinking, what happens when he tries to take that off because of the hair? Will these companies solve that problem for me, I guess, if I'm a man? I don't know. I don't know. Mr. Nip was that one of them? Mr. Nip and nip strips. Nippies. Maybe the nip strips. Well, I remember talking to Ed about like those, that tape and cottonball thing that he had to do. And he said it was really uncomfortable. This was not a comfortable episode for him.
就像我注意到埃德（Ed）遮住乳头时，我一直在想，因为毛发的原因，当他试图把它撕下来时会发生什么？如果我是个男人，这些公司能帮我解决这个问题吗？我不知道，我不知道。Mr. Nip是其中之一吗？Mr. Nip和Nip strips。Nippies。也许是Nip strips。嗯，我记得和埃德谈过他必须用的那种胶带和棉球。他说那真的很不舒服。这一集对他来说并不舒服。
I don't doubt it. I don't doubt it. Well, lady now, Andy is going to be. going to tell Angela how very sorry he is that her cat passed away. This might be leading her maybe toward Andy? Yeah, you know, there's a deleted scene where Dwight and Angela are exchanging instant messages and Dwight's trying to make amends and Angela's not having it. She's getting fed up and she looks over her shoulder towards Dwight and Andy is directly behind him and he thinks Angela is looking at him. Oh. So I think they're planting little seeds here. Well, now you have a talking head, Angela, where you are crying. And you're talking about how Sprinkles was your best friend.
我不怀疑，我不怀疑。嗯，亲爱的，现在安迪要告诉安吉拉他有多么为她的猫去世感到难过。这可能会让她对安迪产生好感吗？是的，你知道，有一个被删减的片段，德怀特和安吉拉在互发即时消息，德怀特试图弥补，但安吉拉不领情。她受够了，她回头看向德怀特，而安迪就在他身后，她以为安吉拉是在看他。哦。所以我认为他们在这里埋下了伏笔。嗯，现在你有一个访谈片段，安吉拉，你在哭。你在说斯普林克尔斯（Sprinkles）是你最好的朋友。
And you're sharing pictures of sprinkles because you're including one from the last Halloween. Yeah. Where you're just a couple of kittens out on the town. A couple of kittens out on the town. Well, lady, we got some mail about this. Yes, about the photos. Yes. from Kate Seber, Mandy Pascal, and Anne-Marie Morrison.
你在分享斯普林克尔斯的照片，因为你还包括了一张去年万圣节的照片。是的，你们就像一对在城里逛街的小猫。一对在城里逛街的小猫。嗯，亲爱的，我们收到了一些关于这个的邮件。是的，关于照片的。是的，来自凯特·西伯（Kate Seber）、曼迪·帕斯卡尔（Mandy Pascal）和安妮-玛丽·莫里森（Anne-Marie Morrison）。
Did you have to do a photo shoot? Or did they just Photoshop a cat into your arms? I did a little bit of both. So if you'll notice a few of the photos, like in particular, there's the picnic blanket one. I'm laying on a picnic blanket. There's a bowl of grapes and I'm holding the cat. If you notice, I am wearing my outfit from beach games.
你们是专门拍了照片吗？还是他们只是把猫PS进你的怀里？我两者都做了一点。所以如果你注意到几张照片，特别是那张野餐垫的照片。我躺在野餐垫上，旁边有一碗葡萄，我抱着猫。如果你注意到了，我穿的是我在《海滩游戏》里的那套衣服。
Oh, yeah. Right? So there's a few photos of me in my beach games outfit. Well, Phil Shea pulled me aside and was like, Angela, we're going to need some photos of you with sprinkles for an upcoming episode. So that day where we started out for beach games on the bus in the parking lot, Phil Shea just said, Angela, I'm going to grab you when I can and we'll just quickly take these, okay?
哦，是的。对吧？所以有几张我穿着《海滩游戏》服装的照片。嗯，菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）把我拉到一边说，安吉拉，我们需要一些你和斯普林克尔斯的照片，用于接下来的一集。所以那天我们在停车场准备出发去海滩游戏时，菲尔·谢就说，安吉拉，我有空就抓你过来，我们快速拍一下，好吗？
So the day that we started beach games, before we went to the beach, you know, when we were still leaving Dunder Mifflin, I snuck off with Phil She. and we took a bunch of those, and I walked over in my own flip-flops, and you can see them in the photo. That's why I'm barefoot. Isn't that weird? That Angela Martin would be barefoot with a pair of flip-flops, and you can see a little eagle on the flip-flops because they're American Eagle. They're my American Eagle flip-flops. That is incredible. Well, I loved you in this talking head so much. You're so good in this whole episode, Ang. Oh, thanks. Thanks so much. Well, up next, Jenna, we have The scene, it starts at 2402, and I titled this scene, the moment the crew turned on us.
所以那天我们开始海滩游戏之前，在我们还没去海滩的时候，你知道，当我们还在离开邓德·米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的时候，我溜出去和菲尔·谢拍了一堆照片，我穿着我自己的夹脚拖鞋走过去，你可以在照片里看到它们。这就是为什么我赤着脚。这不是很奇怪吗？安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）会赤着脚穿着一双夹脚拖鞋，你可以在拖鞋上看到一个小鹰标志，因为那是美国鹰（American Eagle）的。那是我的美国鹰夹脚拖鞋。这太不可思议了。嗯，我太喜欢你在这个访谈片段里的表现了。你在这一整集里都表现得太棒了，安吉拉。哦，谢谢。非常感谢。嗯，接下来，珍娜，我们有这一幕，从24分02秒开始，我把这一幕命名为：剧组对我们忍无可忍的时刻。
Sam, can you play this? I'm having relationship problems. And since you're always having relationship problems, I thought you'd be able to give me some advice. What's wrong? I have this crazy thought that I know is crazy that maybe Dwight killed my cat. When I got home, Sprinkles's body was in the first. freezer where Dwight said he left her. But all my bags of frozen french fries
萨姆，你能播放一下吗？我有感情问题。既然你总是遇到感情问题，我想你应该能给我一些建议。怎么了？我有一个疯狂的想法，我知道这很疯狂，也许德怀特杀了我的猫。当我回家时，斯普林克尔斯的尸体在德怀特说他放她的那个冷冻柜里。但我所有的冷冻薯条袋子
had been clogged to shreds. Something's not right. The vet's doing an autopsy. Angel, I'm sorry. Didn't Roy ever kill one of your cats? I'm more of a dog person. Um, Jenna, do you remember us doing that scene?
都被撕成了碎片。有些不对劲。兽医正在做尸检。安吉拉，我很抱歉。罗伊（Roy）以前杀过你的猫吗？我更喜欢狗。嗯，珍娜，你还记得我们拍那一幕吗？
Yes. We got to break it down for people, because literally the director came over and was like, I'm just going to stop you right now. It was Greg. I know. I know. So I had to pop up over the partition and I start off with like, and then you come.
记得。我们得给观众拆解一下，因为导演真的走过来直接说，我现在就要叫停。是格雷格。我知道，我知道。所以我不得不从隔板后面探出头来，我刚开始说，然后你就来了。
That got me. Right there, I was done. I just started laughing. Just from your head popping over the partition started laughing. No words have come out yet. And every single time you started laughing, then I would start laughing. And then there were times I would get it together and I'd come up over the partition and you'd already be laughing.
那一下击中了我。就在那一刻，我彻底不行了。我开始大笑。仅仅是因为你的头从隔板后面探出来，我就开始笑了。一个字还没说出来呢。而且每次你开始笑，我就会跟着笑。有时候我好不容易忍住了，从隔板后面探出头，结果你已经在笑了。
Yeah. Because I knew what was, I knew there, Angela, you have to imagine from my point of view what it's like to have your tiny blonde head pop up suddenly. It's very funny. And we should also mention this scene was scheduled right before lunch. Yes, and everyone was really hungry. You're always really hungry before lunch because you get called into work at 5 a.m., 6 a.m., but lunch is not until one. So you are hangary. at 1240. Everybody on a set is super hungry at 1240. Even though there's snacks, you want to sit down, you want your 30-minute break, you want to eat a hot meal. And here you have these two actresses who cannot even get one line out. These two gals who are literally laughing so hard they can't speak. And Greg was like, why don't we take a break? Why don't we give you guys a minute to get it together? And I said, oh no, Jenna, they're turning on us. I felt so bad because normally when we would break in a scene, the crew was laughing with you. And other actors would laugh too and be like, you guys, no one was laughing.
是的。因为我知道会发生什么，我知道……安吉拉，你得想象一下，从我的角度看，你那小小的金发脑袋突然探出来是什么感觉。太搞笑了。我们还应该提到这一幕是安排在午餐前拍摄的。是的，每个人都饿坏了。你在午餐前总是很饿，因为你早上5点、6点就被叫去工作，但午餐要到一点才吃。所以你在12点40分的时候会因为饥饿而变得暴躁。片场每个人在12点40分都超级饿。即使有零食，你也想坐下来，想要你的30分钟休息时间，想要吃顿热乎饭。而这里有两个女演员连一句台词都说不出来。这两个姑娘笑得简直说不出话来。格雷格说，我们要不要休息一下？我们要不要给你们一点时间调整一下？我说，哦不，珍娜，他们对我们忍无可忍了。我感到很抱歉，因为通常当我们拍戏笑场时，剧组会跟着一起笑。其他演员也会笑，说，你们这些人……但没人笑。
No, it was just us. We were so tickled to have a scene together. We always were. And this was a comedic scene we got to do. This was funny. Yeah. And I'm surprised we even have one take that's usable because we were laughing so hard. And now, let's just take a minute to talk about Happy Pam Sass because Happy Pam doesn't give Angela anything.
不，只有我们。我们能一起拍戏感到非常开心。我们一直都是这样。这是一场我们能拍的喜剧戏。这很有趣。是的，我很惊讶我们竟然能拍出一条可用的镜头，因为我们笑得太厉害了。现在，让我们花点时间谈谈“快乐帕姆的傲慢”（Happy Pam Sass），因为快乐的帕姆对安吉拉什么都不给。
She's like, hmm, oh, hmm. Can you imagine Angela finally reaching out to Pam and all she gets is, hmm, well, I'm more of a dog person. Are you flipping kidding me? Well, Angela, what do you expect? Anytime Pam has ever tried to comfort or help Angela, Angela just insults her. I think Pam is being self-protective. She's having good boundaries, in my opinion. She's got good boundaries, and she's getting laid.
她就像，嗯，哦，嗯。你能想象安吉拉终于向帕姆求助，得到的却只是“嗯，我更喜欢狗”吗？你在开玩笑吗？嗯，安吉拉，你期待什么呢？每次帕姆试图安慰或帮助安吉拉时，安吉拉只会侮辱她。我认为帕姆是在自我保护。在我看来，她有很好的界限感。她有很好的界限感，而且她过得很滋润。
And she doesn't have time for anybody anymore. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. That is private. Well, Angela, I will say this. We have a fan soapbox, and I think you're going to like it. Oh, I want to hear it. This is from Amy Wagner, Rivka Wasserman, Kayla Kelly, Kaelin White, and Christina Chadbourne.
她再也没时间理任何人了。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。那是私事。嗯，安吉拉，我得说这个。我们有一个粉丝吐槽环节，我想你会喜欢的。哦，我想听听。这是来自艾米·瓦格纳（Amy Wagner）、里夫卡·瓦瑟曼（Rivka Wasserman）、凯拉·凯利（Kayla Kelly）、凯琳·怀特（Kaelin White）和克里斯蒂娜·查德伯恩（Christina Chadbourne）的。
They all wrote in to say this. I hate to break it to you, but Pam is actually responsible for the death of Sprinkles and the breakup of Dwayangela. Pam guilts Angela into seeing Meredith at lunch instead of taking care of Sprinkles, which is why Angela has to ask Dwight to do it and why Sprinkles ends up dead. Oh my gosh. Ladies, I had never put that together. You are right. Pam killed sprinkles. Well, that's going a little far. Pam killed sprinkles. Oh my gosh.
她们都写信来说：我不想打破你的幻想，但帕姆实际上要为斯普林克尔斯的死和德怀特与安吉拉的分手负责。帕姆强迫安吉拉在午餐时去见梅雷迪思（Meredith），而不是照顾斯普林克尔斯，这就是为什么安吉拉不得不让德怀特去做，也是为什么斯普林克尔斯最终死了。天哪。女士们，我从来没把这些联系起来。你们是对的。帕姆杀了斯普林克尔斯。嗯，这有点过分了。帕姆杀了斯普林克尔斯。天哪。
You are so mad at Pam right now. Pam is just happy. Why when Pam gets happy does everyone turn on her? That's something I've noticed, by the way. When Pam becomes assertive, there in particular are a bunch of men on Twitter who tweet about how they don't like Pam sassy. Nobody likes assertive Pam. Well, everyone, you're going to have to live with it.
你现在对帕姆太生气了。帕姆只是很开心。为什么帕姆一开心，每个人都要针对她？顺便说一句，这是我注意到的。当帕姆变得自信时，推特上特别有一群男人发推文说他们不喜欢自信的帕姆。没人喜欢自信的帕姆。嗯，各位，你们得接受这一点。
I don't give a crap about assertive Pam. It's sassy Pam. Guilt trip, Pam. I don't give a shit, Pam, that I have issue with. Well, I thought you'd like that fan soapbox. I very much like it, ladies. Thank you. I feel seen.
我才不在乎自信的帕姆。是傲慢的帕姆。内疚的帕姆。我才不在乎帕姆，我有意见。嗯，我以为你会喜欢那个粉丝吐槽。我非常喜欢，女士们。谢谢。我感觉被理解了。
Well, speaking of Jim and Pam, they're flirting in the break room right now. Oh, I titled this scene. Ready? What is it? Part two of our country song. Ain't no more heartbreak in the break room, baby. Oh, yes. Yes.
嗯，说到吉姆和帕姆，他们现在正在休息室调情。哦，我给这一幕起了个标题。准备好了吗？是什么？我们乡村歌曲的第二部分。宝贝，休息室里再也没有心碎了。哦，是的。是的。
Happy times in the break room, everyone. It's a happy times. Well, the camera crew breaks the fourth wall, and they bring Jim and Pam into the conference room and show them footage of them kissing and driving away. This is huge. Why is the documentary crew getting involved? remember they left Andy floating in a lake but they pulled Jim and Pam aside to show them this footage
休息室里的快乐时光，各位。这是快乐时光。嗯，摄像组打破了第四面墙，他们把吉姆和帕姆带进会议室，给他们看他们接吻并开车离开的录像。这太大了。为什么纪录片组要介入？记得他们把安迪留在湖里漂着，但他们把吉姆和帕姆拉到一边给他们看这段录像。
they didn't say Meredith get out of the way I don't think they saw Meredith they were focused on Michael I don't think the documentary crew could have stopped that accident you know I mean there's been many times where they probably should have stepped in
他们没说“梅雷迪思，让开”，我不认为他们看到了梅雷迪思，他们当时专注于迈克尔。我不认为纪录片组能阻止那场事故，你知道，我的意思是，有很多次他们可能本应该介入的。
and they didn't why now I don't know but they get Pam to admit that she and Jim are dating. This is another Pam Sass moment where she doesn't care. She's like, you know what, we're dating. This is such a cute scene. It's so cute. It has all the feels.
但他们没有，为什么是现在？我不知道，但他们让帕姆承认她和吉姆在约会。这是另一个帕姆的傲慢时刻，她不在乎了。她说，你知道吗，我们在约会。这一幕太可爱了。太可爱了。充满了感觉。
It's really cute. And you and John are so good in it. It's a really great jam, a jam moment. Well, we had a fan question from Linia B who said, what was it like coming back from the break between season three and four to a new relationship, between Jim and Pam. You guys, it was awesome. I had a great time in season four.
真的很可爱。你和约翰在里面表现得太好了。这是一个非常棒的“吉姆和帕姆”时刻。嗯，我们收到了林尼亚·B（Linia B）的粉丝提问，她说，从第三季和第四季之间的休息回来，进入一段新的吉姆和帕姆的关系是什么感觉？伙计们，太棒了。我在第四季过得很开心。
Pam was happy. I was happy. I just spent all day being happy in a comedy, basically. Because I don't know about you, Angela, but I was going to ask you, you have to play this season in a lot of emotional turmoil and mourning. And it takes a toll when you have to play. jealousy or you have to play sad. Like, it does take a toll. Well, it does. Playing sad takes a toll. Playing angry is fun. Yeah. I will say that because I loved the juxtaposition from this very sweet, cute moment with Jim and Pam to me body checking Dwight by the file cabinet. It's so great.
帕姆很开心。我也很开心。我基本上整天都在喜剧里过得很开心。因为我不知道你怎么样，安吉拉，但我本来想问你，你必须在这一季里扮演很多情感动荡和哀悼的角色。当你必须扮演嫉妒或悲伤时，这会造成伤害。是的，确实会。扮演悲伤会造成伤害。扮演愤怒很有趣。是的。我得说，因为我喜欢从吉姆和帕姆这个非常甜蜜、可爱的时刻，到我用身体撞击德怀特（在文件柜旁）的这种并置。太棒了。
And that whole scene that I have with Rain over by accounting where I'm backing my chair into him, we had such a great time with that. That was so much fun. Well, that is a really good scene. Dwight seems to think you're going to feel better after you run the 5K because exercise helps with depression. And you're just like, you're not getting it. I'm not depressed. I'm pissed off. You're grieving. I'm grieving and I'm angry. Yes. So now we go into the conference room, Angela, Jim, Michael, Pam, and Dwight are putting sort of the finishing touches on the fun run plans. And Michael wants a giant check. What is this thing with giant checks? He got a giant check in product recall. Yeah, I don't know. I think I swear, I think it goes back to when he was a
我和雷恩（Rainn）在会计部旁边的那整场戏，我用椅子往后撞他，我们拍得太开心了。那真的很有趣。嗯，那确实是一场好戏。德怀特似乎认为你在跑完5公里后会感觉好些，因为运动有助于缓解抑郁。而你只是觉得，你不明白。我没有抑郁。我气疯了。你在悲伤。我在悲伤，而且我很生气。是的。所以现在我们进入会议室，安吉拉、吉姆、迈克尔、帕姆和德怀特正在为“趣味跑”计划做最后的润色。迈克尔想要一张巨型支票。这个巨型支票是怎么回事？他在产品召回那一集里也拿到了一张巨型支票。是的，我不知道。我发誓，我觉得这要追溯到他还是个
little kid and that owl came to his assembly in a costume with props. This is how you get people's attention, how you get them to care about things. You have big props and costumes and outfits. Why have we not explored Michael's feelings about carrot top? The most famous prop comic. I think he loves carrot top and I think he loves, who's the guy that hit all the watermelons? Gallagher. Gallagher. Yeah, I think you're right. Well, here's what he wants. He wants a giant check, even though it will eat up 25% of their funds. He wants a rabies doctor to present the check. Yeah.
小孩子的时候，那只猫头鹰穿着戏服带着道具来到他的集会。这就是你吸引人们注意力、让他们关心事物的方式。你有大型道具、戏服和服装。为什么我们还没有探讨迈克尔对卡罗特·托普（Carrot Top）的感受？最著名的道具喜剧演员。我想他喜欢卡罗特·托普，我想他喜欢……那个把所有西瓜都砸碎的家伙是谁？加拉格尔（Gallagher）。加拉格尔。是的，我想你是对的。嗯，这就是他想要的。他想要一张巨型支票，即使这会耗尽他们25%的资金。他想要一位狂犬病医生来颁发支票。是的。
Jim suggests maybe they hire a nurse, like by the hour like you would for a party. Michael's like sounds great. Dwight suggests they just donate the money to Meredith's son's college fund. Dwight is the only person making sense in this meeting. Yes, surprisingly, Dwight has the best. idea. Jim and Pam are just egging Michael on. But Michael's like, have you seen that kid? He's not going to
吉姆建议也许他们可以雇一个护士，就像派对那样按小时计费。迈克尔说听起来不错。德怀特建议他们直接把钱捐给梅雷迪思儿子的大学基金。德怀特是这次会议中唯一清醒的人。是的，令人惊讶的是，德怀特有最好的主意。吉姆和帕姆只是在怂恿迈克尔。但迈克尔说，你们见过那个孩子吗？他不会去
college. Exactly. Well, I think we should take a break here, Jenna. And when we come back, we might need to talk about a dangling participle. It's an accidental flashing. He did say come in. I agree. Yes. All right. We'll be back. All right, we are back, and Pam's about to get the shock of her life. Jenna, how did you film this? How did it? Okay, so, so Pam is, you know, like going in to tell Michael something, right? She knocks on the door.
上大学的。没错。嗯，我觉得我们应该在这里休息一下，珍娜。当我们回来时，我们可能需要谈谈一个悬垂分词。那是一次意外的走光。他确实说了“进来”。我同意。是的。好的，我们马上回来。好的，我们回来了，帕姆即将经历她一生中最震惊的时刻。珍娜，你是怎么拍这一幕的？怎么拍的？好的，所以，帕姆，你知道，正要进去告诉迈克尔一些事情，对吧？她敲了敲门。
She wants to tell him that 5K means five kilometers, not 5,000 miles. Right, right. And he says, come in, and she opens the door, and he's decided to change into his running outfit in his office. Yeah. And he is nude. from the waist down. And Pam is shocked. Well, this was a really interesting scene to film.
她想告诉他5K意味着5公里，而不是5000英里。对，对。他说，进来，她打开门，他决定在办公室里换上他的跑步装备。是的。他腰部以下是裸体的。帕姆震惊了。嗯，这是一场拍摄起来非常有趣的戏。
We had a fan question from Tara Nunez. When Pam walks in on Michael Naked, what was Steve actually wearing? Steve was actually wearing like a flesh-colored speedo. It's still not pleasant to look at, guys. Those reactions are honest. Whenever anyone has to wear a flesh-covered anything, it's just off-putting. Yeah, you kind of look like a, like a Ken doll or a bar. Barbie doll or something. It's very weird. You still are seeing outlines. Right. Anyway, the thing that was
我们收到了塔拉·努涅斯（Tara Nunez）的粉丝提问。当帕姆撞见裸体的迈克尔时，史蒂夫实际上穿了什么？史蒂夫实际上穿了一条肉色的泳裤。伙计们，这看起来仍然不愉快。那些反应是真实的。每当有人不得不穿肉色的任何东西时，这都很让人反感。是的，你看起来有点像肯娃娃或芭比娃娃之类的。非常奇怪。你仍然能看到轮廓。对。无论如何，这里
difficult here when we were shooting it and we shot this several times because Pam has to get far enough into the room and open the door wide enough that the camera can see Michael. Because in my early takes of this, I can see him, but the camera wasn't catching it because I was reacting too quickly. You're pulling the door shut too fast. Yeah. Yeah. So the first thing that we did was Greg said, why don't you be looking at the paper longer and like give a look to camera as you're opening the door? Like, can you believe he thinks it's 5,000 miles so that I can get the door open wider for camera to see him almost before I see him? So that's how we ended up fixing that problem. But it was very, very funny.
困难的是，当我们拍摄它时，我们拍了好几次，因为帕姆必须足够深入房间，并且把门开得足够大，摄像机才能看到迈克尔。因为在我早期的拍摄中，我能看到他，但摄像机没拍到，因为我的反应太快了。你把门关得太快了。是的。是的。所以我们做的第一件事是格雷格说，你为什么不看纸的时间长一点，然后在开门时给摄像机一个眼神？就像，你能相信他认为那是5000英里吗？这样我就可以在看到他之前，先把门开得更宽，让摄像机拍到他。所以这就是我们最终解决那个问题的方法。但这非常、非常有趣。
We were laughing a lot during this scene. lady after this aired a friend of mine and i were talking about this episode and i'll never forget it because i heard a term i'd never heard before in my life and they said this is this is a thing sometimes guys will do i don't know where they do it but it's called shirt cocking oh and it's a thing okay and if you look it up it says it's a shirt cocking is a verb and it's when a man wears a t-shirt but goes naked from the waist down Oh, oh, listen to this. This practice is a natural outgrowth of Burning Man events, which value radical self-expression, but are held in clothing optional environments.
我们在这一幕中笑了很多。亲爱的，这一集播出后，我和一个朋友谈论这一集，我永远不会忘记它，因为我听到了一个我一生中从未听说过的词，他们说这是一种现象，有时男人们会这样做，我不知道他们在哪里做的，但它被称为“shirt cocking”。哦，这是一种现象，好的。如果你查一下，它说“shirt cocking”是一个动词，是指一个男人穿着T恤，但腰部以下裸体。哦，哦，听这个。这种做法是火人节（Burning Man）活动的自然产物，该活动重视激进的自我表达，但在服装可选的环境中举行。
Oh. Mm-hmm. I've never been to Burning Man. Well, neither have I, but apparently this happens there, guys. Well, I've never been shirt-cocked either. I've never been shirt-cocked, but beware. it happens. It's a thing. I guess it's a thing in the desert, guys, where people get together to have radical experiences. Well, Michael Shirtcock's Pam. And Pam tells Jim that the incident is now burned into her brain.
哦。嗯哼。我从来没去过火人节。嗯，我也没去过，但显然男人们在那里会这样做。嗯，我也从来没被“shirt-cocked”过。我从来没被“shirt-cocked”过，但要小心。它确实发生了。这是一种现象。我想这在沙漠里是一种现象，伙计们，人们聚在一起进行激进的体验。嗯，迈克尔对帕姆“shirt-cocked”了。帕姆告诉吉姆，这件事现在烙印在她的脑海里了。
Back in the break room. Jim and Pam don't hang out at front reception anymore. They just go to the break room to hang out and have their little conversations. Yeah, happiness in the break room. The break room is a great place now. Well, Michael knocks on the break room door and enters. He's trying to teach Pam how to properly enter a room. Oh, can I come in? Yeah. Yeah. And Pam is like, you said come in.
回到休息室。吉姆和帕姆不再在前台闲逛了。他们只是去休息室闲逛，进行他们的小对话。是的，休息室里的快乐。休息室现在是个好地方。嗯，迈克尔敲了敲休息室的门并走了进来。他试图教帕姆如何正确地进入一个房间。哦，我可以进来吗？是的。是的。帕姆说，你说“进来”。
You said, come in. Well, Pam has a major PamSass moment. She says, I didn't see where it started, but I saw where it ended. Wow. I couldn't believe that line. Wow. Pam is really just saying anything on her. mind now. You're really, I... See? You're right. Yeah. She's looking up celebrity porn on the
你说，“进来”。嗯，帕姆有一个重大的“帕姆傲慢”时刻。她说，我没看到它从哪开始，但我看到了它在哪结束。哇。我不敢相信那句台词。哇。帕姆现在真的在说她脑子里想的任何事。你真的，我……看？你是对的。是的。她在电脑上查名人色情片。
computer. She's sassing Angela. She's sassing Michael. She's not going to run in your stupid fun run. It's true. Let's get to the fun run, lady. Let's do it. We're in the parking lot. Jan is checking people in. Creed registers. He's very disappointed. There's no prize money. We find out, by the way, that Creed's birthday is November 1st and he's going to be 82. I know. So ridiculous. That was so ridiculous.
她在对安吉拉傲慢。她在对迈克尔傲慢。她才不会去跑你那愚蠢的趣味跑。这是真的。让我们进入趣味跑吧，亲爱的。我们开始吧。我们在停车场。简（Jan）正在给人们登记。克里德（Creed）注册了。他非常失望。没有奖金。顺便说一句，我们发现克里德的生日是11月1日，他要82岁了。我知道。太荒谬了。那太荒谬了。
Jan tells Pam to stay away from her man. Heard she was peeping in on him. I know. Oh, that was so fun to do. I love doing that scene with Molora where she's just putting Pam in her place. And Pam is like, I... But you know, guys, Jan is no longer our boss.
简告诉帕姆离她的男人远点。听说她在偷看他。我知道。哦，那太有趣了。我喜欢和莫洛拉（Melora）拍那场戏，她只是让帕姆认清自己的位置。帕姆说，我……但你知道，伙计们，简不再是我们的老板了。
Yeah. She holds no authority over us. She is just there. as Michael's girlfriend. Well, I have to tell you something. So all of this is happening. While you have this scene between Pam and Jan going on, there is a scene between Bob Vance, Phyllis, and Angela.
是的。她对我们没有任何权威。她只是作为迈克尔的女朋友在那里。嗯，我得告诉你一件事。所以这一切都在发生。当帕姆和简之间的那场戏正在进行时，鲍勃·万斯（Bob Vance）、菲利斯（Phyllis）和安吉拉之间有一场戏。
So in the background where Toby is stretching, Angela is standing there, and Phyllis and Bob walk up. And Bob points to her shirt and says, oh, oh, is that the cat? And he turns to Phyllis and says, is that the one that Meredith? and Phyllis quickly cuts him off and goes, no, no, no. And then Angela spits on Bob. What? And storms off.
所以在托比（Toby）正在拉伸的背景里，安吉拉站在那里，菲利斯和鲍勃走了过来。鲍勃指着她的衬衫说，哦，哦，那是那只猫吗？他转向菲利斯说，那是梅雷迪思……的那只吗？菲利斯迅速打断他说，不，不，不。然后安吉拉向鲍勃吐口水。什么？然后冲走了。
What is happening in that scene? Did Meredith do something to one of your other cats? I have so many questions. What has Meredith done to one of her cats? It certainly might explain why Angela really does not like Meredith. But, man, Angela is talking about angry. She spits at Bob. Wow.
那场戏里发生了什么？梅雷迪思对你的另一只猫做了什么吗？我有太多的问题了。梅雷迪思对她的猫做了什么？这肯定能解释为什么安吉拉真的不喜欢梅雷迪思。但是，天哪，安吉拉在谈论愤怒。她向鲍勃吐口水。哇。
Yeah. Well, now Michael welcomes everyone and he gives a speech where he sort of warns everybody of the dangers of rabies in the background then Daryl is feeding a peanut to a squirrel. That is such a random funny joke. That's a very Simpsons-esque joke if you ask me. I loved it. And I love Michael was like, stop and he's like, but he's so happy. well then we have Elizabeth the stripper is back Jackie de Botton she walks in in this little nurse's outfit to present Michael with the giant check made out to science just science yeah $340 to science just a piece of cardboard that cost $200 for nothing and when Michael sees Elizabeth in her outfit he's like Oh, my gosh, you went back for your degree.
是的。嗯，现在迈克尔欢迎大家，他发表了一场演讲，警告大家狂犬病的危险，背景里达里尔（Daryl）正在喂松鼠吃花生。那是一个非常随机有趣的笑话。如果你问我，那是一个非常像《辛普森一家》的笑话。我喜欢它。我喜欢迈克尔说“停下”，而他却说“但他太开心了”。嗯，然后伊丽莎白（Elizabeth）那个脱衣舞娘回来了，杰基·德·巴顿（Jackie de Botton），她穿着这套小护士装走进来，给迈克尔颁发那张写给“科学”的巨型支票，仅仅是科学。是的，340美元给科学，只是一块花了200美元的纸板，什么都没换来。当迈克尔看到伊丽莎白穿着她的服装时，他说，哦，天哪，你回去拿学位了。
Yeah. Amazing. Well, I have a little wardrobe tidbit. I think I know your tidbit. Oh, really? Go. All right. Carrie told me that this nurse's outfit was custom made.
是的。太神奇了。嗯，我有一个小小的服装花絮。我想我知道你的花絮。哦，真的吗？说吧。好的，凯莉（Carrie）告诉我这套护士装是定制的。
And if you notice, she had to make it a red circle with a white cross in the middle. And this is because the red cross does not like their symbol to be used for fictional content. so she could not have a red cross in a white circle. She had to invert it. Yes, lady. Well, do you know that that is the same costume that Angela Martin wore in season seven? They saved that costume. Season seven, the Halloween episode, where we have a costume contest.
如果你注意到了，她不得不把它做成一个中间有白十字的红圆圈。这是因为红十字会不喜欢他们的标志被用于虚构内容。所以她不能在白圆圈里用红十字。她不得不把它反过来。是的，亲爱的。嗯，你知道那和安吉拉·马丁在第七季穿的是同一套服装吗？他们保留了那套服装。第七季，万圣节那一集，我们有服装比赛。
I wore that outfit. What? Yep. I wore that outfit, the exact same one. And it was a little too big for me. So I had to wear a little lace tank top underneath it. And, you know, we'll get to season seven. But they gave me the chicken cutlets to make everything a little bigger.
我穿了那套衣服。什么？是的。我穿了那套衣服，完全一样的一套。它对我来说有点大。所以我不得不在下面穿一件蕾丝背心。而且，你知道，我们会讲到第七季。但他们给了我鸡胸肉垫（chicken cutlets）让一切看起来大一点。
Yep. Same costume. Wow. I guess in our Dunder Mifflin world, this is like a little costume that you could buy, I guess. But Carrie Bennett told me that she made it. There it is. You're wearing it. And you can see.
是的。同一套服装。哇。我想在我们的邓德·米夫林世界里，这就像你可以买到的一套小服装。但凯莉·贝内特（Carrie Bennett）告诉我她制作了它。就在那里。你穿着它。你可以看到。
It's this same white cross, the same hat. I just have a tank top because it's a little big. That is crazy. I know. Could I say? Well, speaking of crazy, Michael is now downing some Fetuccini Alfredo, just downing it. He's carboloading before the run. Is that a thing?
它是同一个白十字，同一顶帽子。我只是穿了一件背心，因为它有点大。这太疯狂了。我能说吗？嗯，说到疯狂，迈克尔现在正在狂吃意大利宽面（Fettuccini Alfredo），简直是在狂吃。他在跑步前进行碳水化合物负荷。这是真的吗？
Do people carboload? They do, but like not moments before they run, right? I looked it up. There's two things happening in this moment. First of all, we have a faky bag catch. Fanky bag, faky prop bag, that bag that bag that Dwight is holding is not a real bag. It's one of the ones that doesn't make noise. And here's the thing about carboloading.
人们会进行碳水化合物负荷吗？他们会，但不是在跑步前几分钟，对吧？我查了一下。这一刻发生了两件事。首先，我们有一个假袋子。假袋子，假道具袋，德怀特拿着的那个袋子不是真袋子。它是那种不会发出声音的袋子之一。关于碳水化合物负荷，事情是这样的。
So, guys, this is something that people will do, but it's recommended that you do it the week before a high... The week before. Yeah, a week before a high endurance activity. Yeah, the reason why you do this carboload, the week before, is to boost the glycid. and that stored in your muscles, right? So you can sort of burn on that while you're doing your high endurance activity. You don't do it minutes before. It's so gross.
所以，伙计们，这是人们会做的事情，但建议你在高强度活动前一周做。前一周。是的，高强度活动前一周。是的，你在一周前进行这种碳水化合物负荷的原因是增加糖原。储存在你的肌肉里，对吧？这样你可以在进行高强度活动时消耗它。你不会在几分钟前做。太恶心了。
So gross. It's so gross. A lot of people wrote in asking how much fetachini Steve had to eat. Pretty much none. I don't know if you notice, but we cut away before he has to really swallow the fetuccini. They had a bucket there. So he would shove a bunch in his mouth and he would spit it out. Thank God, because it was almost 100 degrees that week every day.
太恶心了。太恶心了。很多人写信问史蒂夫吃了多少意大利宽面。几乎没有。我不知道你有没有注意到，我们在他真正吞下意大利宽面之前就切掉了。他们那里有个桶。所以他会往嘴里塞一大把，然后吐出来。谢天谢地，因为那一周每天几乎都有100度。
Yeah. And we were outside. Hot, outside eating fettuccini. Blot. Can we talk about the ginormous gun that Dwight shoots off to start the race? Not a starter's pistol. An actual gun with actual bullets in it. Obviously, we shot off blanks, but what the heck?
是的。我们在外面。热，在外面吃意大利宽面。砰。我们能谈谈德怀特开枪开始比赛的那把巨大的枪吗？不是发令枪。是一把带有真子弹的真枪。显然，我们发射的是空包弹，但到底是怎么回事？
I know. So according to Dundrapedia, Dwight uses a six-inch colt anaconda, and it's the same caliber gun used by Dirty Harry. Well, it's ridiculous. I believe, though, that he would have some gun that Clint Eastwood fired, like a dirty hairy gun. That tracks. It's perfect for his character. Well, the race is underway.
我知道。根据Dundrapedia，德怀特使用的是六英寸柯尔特蟒蛇（Colt Anaconda），它和《肮脏哈里》（Dirty Harry）使用的是同一种口径的枪。嗯，这太荒谬了。不过我相信，他会拥有克林特·伊斯特伍德（Clint Eastwood）开过的那种枪，比如肮脏哈里的枪。这很符合逻辑。这对他这个角色来说很完美。嗯，比赛开始了。
We fired this gun. Creed, Stanley, and Oscar immediately get into a cab. Yeah. Which is amazing. Stanley says he will work out today. He will work out a way to avoid running for a stupid cause. Yeah. They all three have talking heads and deleted scenes that talk about why they're not doing it.
我们开了枪。克里德、斯坦利（Stanley）和奥斯卡（Oscar）立即上了一辆出租车。是的。这太神奇了。斯坦利说他今天会锻炼。他会想出办法避免为了一个愚蠢的事业而跑步。是的。他们三个人都有访谈片段和被删减的片段，谈论他们为什么不参加。
Stanley had an alt that said when he runs, his feet swell up to the size of a pot roast, and you don't want to see that. Oh, well, Angela Martin certainly would not. She does not like gross feet. No. Well, we sort of see everybody's approach, right? Like, Andy's going to run. Michael's going really fast. And this is when we find out that Pam and Jim are happily in last place together, just strolling. Andy's going to draft behind Kevin. Well, now we have a scene that I love so much where Jan is handing out water to the runners. She's somehow moved from the starting line where she was checking people in to a new table where she's handing out waters and people haven't even gotten to her yet. I found that interesting.
斯坦利有一个备选方案，说当他跑步时，他的脚会肿得像烤肉一样大，你不会想看到那个的。哦，嗯，安吉拉·马丁肯定不想。她不喜欢恶心的脚。不。嗯，我们算是看到了每个人的方法，对吧？比如，安迪要跑。迈克尔跑得非常快。这就是我们发现帕姆和吉姆快乐地并列最后，只是在散步的时候。安迪要跟在凯文（Kevin）后面。嗯，现在我们有一场我非常喜欢的戏，简正在给跑者发水。她不知怎么从她登记的起跑线移动到了一个新的桌子，在那里她正在发水，而人们甚至还没到她那里。我觉得这很有趣。
She obviously drove, I guess, to this new spot. Well, Michael refuses to take the water. He explains that rabies victims have to live with an irrational hatred of water, so it's really the least he can do to refuse the water. Well, I looked it up, Angela, you know last week I told you a lot about rabies and the importance of getting a shot if you're ever bitten by an animal. Hey, I did not look it up. In fact, I wrote myself a note, asked Jenna, rabies expert.
她显然开车，我想，到了这个新地点。嗯，迈克尔拒绝喝水。他解释说，狂犬病患者必须忍受对水的非理性仇恨，所以拒绝喝水是他能做的最起码的事。嗯，我查了一下，安吉拉，你知道上周我告诉了你很多关于狂犬病以及如果你被动物咬伤后注射疫苗的重要性。嘿，我没查。事实上，我给自己写了一张便条，问珍娜，狂犬病专家。
Is this true? No, you did not. I have to say I do know a lot more about rabies than I ever thought I would, thanks to this podcast. But this condition is called hydrophobia. And it is an irrational fear of water. And it does present itself in the advanced stages of the disease of rabies. But here's why. Basically, patients start to fear liquids because it is so painful to swallow. Like they don't want to drink or eat anything. So it's not like having water touch them would bother them, but ingesting anything becomes so painful that that's why. This is horrible. This is horrible.
这是真的吗？不，你没有。我不得不说，多亏了这个播客，我确实比我以前想象的要了解更多关于狂犬病的知识。但这种情况被称为“恐水症”。这是一种对水的非理性恐惧。它确实出现在狂犬病疾病的晚期阶段。但原因如下。基本上，患者开始害怕液体，因为吞咽非常痛苦。就像他们不想喝或吃任何东西一样。所以并不是水碰到他们会困扰他们，而是摄入任何东西都变得非常痛苦，这就是原因。这太可怕了。这太可怕了。
Rabies is a horrible disease. I cannot stress enough how important it is to get that shot if you are bitten by an animal. Well, we also didn't mention that Toby ran by and took a swig of water, but through most of it on Jan. Yes, this is true. Well, Toby's doing great, and we're about to find out why. Michael is not doing well because of the fetuccini. Yeah. But Dwight tells him he's going to be fine.
狂犬病是一种可怕的疾病。我怎么强调如果你被动物咬伤后去注射疫苗的重要性都不为过。嗯，我们也没提到托比跑过去喝了一口水，但大部分都洒在了简身上。是的，这是真的。嗯，托比表现得很好，我们马上就会知道原因。迈克尔因为意大利宽面表现不好。是的。但德怀特告诉他他会没事的。
You'll probably still win because he put a modium in Toby's coffee. Michael's so excited. He's like, excellent! And then goes, wait, don't you mean X-Lox? Yes. Dwight has helped Toby. Yeah. I want to point something out about this scene.
你可能还是会赢，因为他在托比的咖啡里放了易蒙停（Imodium）。迈克尔太兴奋了。他说，太棒了！然后说，等等，你不是指X-Lox吗？是的。德怀特帮助了托比。是的。我想指出关于这一幕的一点。
During this scene, I swear Michael and Dwight run past Oscars House, or at least the location that we used for Oscar's House. So I looked it up and yes, we are filming on the same street in Sherman Oaks that has Oscars House. We filmed there a lot. It was really close to our set. and yeah, I think we run past the location of Oscar's house. We filmed there a lot for all those reasons and also this particular neighborhood in Sherman Oaks has really great old, old, huge trees that might resemble the East Coast more than normally what L.A. would look like. Yeah. Meanwhile, Andy's nipples are starting to chafe
在这一幕中，我发誓迈克尔和德怀特跑过了奥斯卡的家，或者至少是我们用作奥斯卡家的那个地点。所以我查了一下，是的，我们是在谢尔曼奥克斯（Sherman Oaks）的同一条街上拍摄的，那里有奥斯卡的家。我们经常在那里拍摄。它离我们的片场很近。是的，我想我们跑过了奥斯卡家的地点。我们因为所有这些原因经常在那里拍摄，而且谢尔曼奥克斯的这个特定社区有非常棒的、古老的、巨大的树木，可能比洛杉矶通常看起来的样子更像东海岸。是的。与此同时，安迪的乳头开始磨损了。
and Creed, Stanley, and Oscar are at like an outside cafe. They've already ordered another round of drinks. I like their style. Yes. And Pam and Jim are now going to stop at an estate sale. I love estate sales. My mom, this makes me think of my mom, whenever we went anywhere, any kind of road trip. If we saw a sign that said yard sale, garage sale, estate sale, my mom would literally pull off the road. Well, in my sophomore year of college, I got my own apartment. And the summer before I went back to school, my mom took me around to estate sales and garage sales. And that's where I bought all of my dishes and my pots and pans and all the stuff I was going to need for my kitchen. And I still have some of that stuff. I still have a baking dish from one of the garage sales that we went to in order to
而克里德、斯坦利和奥斯卡在一家户外咖啡馆。他们已经点了第二轮饮料了。我喜欢他们的风格。是的。而帕姆和吉姆现在要在一个遗产拍卖会上停下来。我喜欢遗产拍卖会。我妈妈，这让我想起了我妈妈，无论我们去哪里，任何公路旅行。如果我们看到一个写着“庭院拍卖”、“车库拍卖”、“遗产拍卖”的牌子，我妈妈真的会把车开下路。嗯，在我大学二年级时，我有了自己的公寓。在我回学校前的那个夏天，我妈妈带我去了遗产拍卖会和车库拍卖会。那就是我买所有餐具、锅碗瓢盆以及我厨房需要的所有东西的地方。我仍然保留着其中一些东西。我仍然有一个来自我们去过的车库拍卖会之一的烤盘，为了
get all my stuff for college. I still have a little piece of like kitchen art. It's like a pear and some grapes and it's like someone made this, someone made the image and then got a piece of wood and then shalacked over it. Do you know what I mean? Yes. And it's this sort of kitchy little piece of kitchen art and I got it at a garage sale. I love that. I did that too. I love estate sales and garage sales because I think they're such a great way to recycle and reuse. You know, you don't have to buy everything new. When someone's done with it, Use it. I love that. I love that too. I always love the idea of what that story was. What did that green bowl with that one little chip? What was that about? Now I'm going to have it. Yes. I agree. Well, now I love that Ryan and Fancy Corporate calls Dunder Mifflin, and no one is answering. And he gets this message that says, you've reached the offices of Dundermifflin Scranton. Currently, the entire staff is out doing the Michael Scott DM. S-M-S-M-C, rabies awareness, pro-am, fun-run race.
给我上大学买所有东西。我仍然有一件小小的厨房艺术品。它是一个梨和一些葡萄，就像有人制作了这个，有人制作了图像，然后拿了一块木头，然后在上面涂了虫胶。你知道我的意思吗？是的。它是那种俗气的厨房艺术品，我是在车库拍卖会上买的。我喜欢那个。我也做过。我喜欢遗产拍卖会和车库拍卖会，因为我认为它们是回收和再利用的好方法。你知道，你不必买所有全新的东西。当有人用完它时，使用它。我喜欢那个。我也喜欢那个。我总是喜欢那个故事是什么的想法。那个带有一个小缺口的绿色碗？那是怎么回事？现在我要拥有它了。是的。我同意。嗯，现在我喜欢瑞安（Ryan）和花哨的企业部打电话给邓德·米夫林，没人接听。他得到了这个信息，说，你已经联系了邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿办公室。目前，全体员工都在进行迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）的D-M-S-M-C，狂犬病意识，职业-业余，趣味跑比赛。
And then Michael chimes in. That's all your voice. And Michael chimes in and goes, for the cure. And then Pam says, leave a message. I thought it was hilarious. I thought it was so funny. And Ryan is like, oh, well, you know Michael was just hovering over Pam's shoulder as she created that outgoing message.
接着迈克尔插话了。那全是你的声音。迈克尔插话说道，为了治愈。然后帕姆说，请留言。我觉得这太搞笑了。我觉得太好玩了。瑞安说，哦，你知道迈克尔只是在帕姆创建那个外发留言时，一直在她肩膀后面徘徊。
Oh, my goodness. I would love to have seen how many, like, ways that he made or say it. until they got it right. Well, now, lady, Dwight is going to try to sweet talk, Angela. He is. He runs up next to her, tells her she looks cute as a button. She's not into it. She doesn't want to hear it.
天哪。我真想看看他到底试了多少种方式，才录制成功。好了，现在，女士，德怀特要试着去讨好安吉拉了。他确实这么做了。他跑到她身边，告诉她她看起来可爱极了。她不吃这一套。她不想听。
And there were a lot of things that made this scene a little trickier than it looks. We had to deliver all of our dialogue while running, but we couldn't run so fast that you would never see Steve, who was positioned just behind us and between us. We couldn't run too close to one another, and we had to pace this out because the camera was getting us in the foreground and Michael in the background. I imagine it was difficult. Also, we only had so much sidewalk. Well, we had a specific place we had to stop, too, on the sidewalk, and we had to try to hit that
有很多因素让这一幕比看起来更棘手。我们必须在奔跑的同时说出所有的台词，但我们不能跑得太快，否则你就看不到史蒂夫了，他当时就站在我们身后，在我们中间。我们不能跑得离彼此太近，而且我们必须控制节奏，因为摄像机在前景拍我们，在背景拍迈克尔。我想这很难。而且，人行道就那么长。嗯，我们在人行道上也有一个必须停下的特定位置，我们必须努力每次都准确地到达那个位置。
same mark every time because then we see the neighbor, and we have this great moment that I love where we're like, it's nothing. And Dwight's like, I'm robbing her, and I'm like, it's fine. And then at the same time, we're like, it's nothing. and then we go right back to our conversation we were having. Well, we had a fan question from Steph Bailey and Debbie Kay. Kind of more of a statement, Angela, for not being a runner, you have really great form. Do I?
每次都停在同一个标记点，因为接着我们看到了邻居，我们有这一段我很喜欢的精彩时刻，我们说，没什么。德怀特说，我在抢劫她，我说，没关系。然后同时，我们说，没什么。然后我们又回到了刚才的谈话中。嗯，我们收到了斯蒂芬·贝利和黛比·凯的粉丝提问。安吉拉，这更像是一种陈述，作为一个不常跑步的人，你的姿势真的很棒。我有吗？
I thought so, too. I thought you were a very cute runner. Well, thank you. I mean, I ran cross country in high school, you guys. Maybe somewhere in the back of my brain, it was still there. Well, there you go. When were you running cross country? also playing basketball and trombone. I don't understand. And tennis. And I was a cheerleader.
我也这么认为。我觉得你跑起来很可爱。谢谢。我是说，我高中时参加过越野跑，伙计们。也许在我大脑深处的某个地方，记忆还在。好吧，原来如此。你是什么时候参加越野跑的？还打篮球和吹长号。我不明白。还有网球。而且我还是个啦啦队长。
I was busy in high school, Jenna. This was my mom's attitude was if you're busy, you don't have time for trouble. Well, you were busy. I was very busy. I also want to read you this letter from Patrick Wright. Okay. Because I agree with Patrick. Here's what Patrick had to say. I really wanted to express my respect for Angela as an actress, especially in this episode. She is a mixture of tragically funny and also just heartbreaking. She gives such a fabulous nuanced performance throughout this entire episode. We as an audience truly feel for her hurt and anger throughout the story and my heart broke as she runs away from Dwight with her adoration of the man she loves, but at the same time shattered. The performances from everyone in the cast was brilliant as always, but I,
我在高中时很忙，珍娜。我妈妈的态度是，如果你很忙，你就没时间惹麻烦。嗯，你确实很忙。我非常忙。我还想读一下帕特里克·赖特给你的这封信。好的。因为我同意帕特里克的观点。这是帕特里克要说的话。我真的很想表达我对安吉拉作为一名演员的敬意，特别是在这一集中。她既悲剧又滑稽，同时也令人心碎。她在整集中都贡献了极其精彩且细腻的表演。作为观众，我们真切地感受到了她在整个故事中的伤害和愤怒，当她带着对所爱之人的崇拜跑离德怀特时，我的心都碎了，但同时又感到破碎。所有演员的表演一如既往地出色，但是，我，
I felt compelled to single out Angela for her marvelous acting. Aw, that is so nice. Thank you. I so appreciate that. We really feel Angela being torn here because Dwight admits he killed sprinkles. He mercy killed sprinkles. And, you know, Dwight tried to do it in the kindest way and for all the right reasons in his mind, right? Yeah. in his perspective and gave her an heistamines until she fell asleep. And then Angel's like, but then she threw them up and she tried to claw her way out. And she's like, why didn't you talk to me about this first? Like how was this not a conversation? If this was the solution you thought
我感到必须特别提一下安吉拉那精湛的演技。噢，太好了。谢谢。我非常感激。我们真的感受到了安吉拉在这里的挣扎，因为德怀特承认他杀了斯普林克尔斯。他安乐死了斯普林克尔斯。而且，你知道，德怀特在他看来是以最仁慈的方式，出于所有正确的理由去做的，对吧？是的。从他的角度来看，他给她喂了抗组胺药，直到她睡着。然后安吉拉说，但后来她吐了出来，她试图挣扎着爬出来。她说，你为什么不先跟我商量一下？这怎么就不是一次对话呢？如果这是你认为的解决方案，
needed to happen, why not talk to me about this? And there are sad moments to the scene. And there's these moments where obviously there's a joke written, but I have to say it really earnestly like the cat heaven is a beautiful place but you don't get there if you're euthanized you know yeah and but one of the notes gregg gave me was as you run away you know dwight's like reaching out for you and i say you don't understand and i kind of start to cry as i run away and he's he said you know what dwight isn't getting is that this is unforgivable for you. Yeah. And you love this man, but he has severed this bond. You don't think you can be with him anymore. But Dwight doesn't know that yet, but you know it. Well, I've had this happen in
需要发生，为什么不跟我谈谈？这一幕中有悲伤的时刻。有些时刻显然是写好的笑话，但我必须真诚地说出来，比如猫咪天堂是个美丽的地方，但如果你被安乐死了就去不了那里，你知道的。是的，格雷格给我的笔记之一是，当你跑开时，你知道德怀特在向你伸手，我说你根本不懂，我跑开时开始哭泣。他说，你知道德怀特没意识到的是，这对你来说是不可原谅的。是的。你爱这个男人，但他切断了这种联系。你觉得你不能再和他在一起了。但德怀特还不知道这一点，但你知道。嗯，我经历过这种情况，
relationships where you're dating and you're so in love and the relationship is just all promise and optimism. And then something happens and the person reacts or acts in such a way. that you realize there is a fundamental difference of values. Yeah, and she knows it, and she knows she can't see him the same way. And it will take a very, very, very long time as we know for her to forgive him. Yeah. Well, guess what? Jim and Pam bought a lamp.
在恋爱关系中，你们正在约会，彼此深爱，这段关系充满了希望和乐观。然后发生了一些事情，对方以某种方式反应或行事。让你意识到价值观存在根本差异。是的，她知道，她知道她不能再用同样的眼光看他了。正如我们所知，她要原谅他需要很长很长很长的时间。是的。好吧，猜猜怎么着？吉姆和帕姆买了一盏灯。
Just the base of a lamp. Yeah, it was $8 and now Jim gets to carry it. It's an odd choice, this green lamp. It looks like two octopus tentacles are holding hands or something. I don't know what's happening with it. How does Jim feel about Pam's taste if this is the lamp she wanted to buy? Is he concerned about moving in together one day? Maybe sharing a house.
只是灯座。是的，花了8美元，现在吉姆得扛着它。这是一个奇怪的选择，这盏绿色的灯。看起来像两只章鱼触手在牵手什么的。我不知道它怎么了。如果这是帕姆想买的灯，吉姆对帕姆的品味怎么看？他是否担心有一天会住在一起？也许合租一栋房子。
This lamp is not great. But also, Michael is really struggling. Phyllis and Bob pass him up. I mean, he's laying on the ground. His lips are all white. doesn't look good. He doesn't look like he's going to make it. In the meantime, Toby wins the race. Yeah. And I thought it was so perfect that Kelly is at the finish line, like on her phone. Yes. And he's like, where are we? And she's like, we're about five kilometers from the office. And Toby's like, why didn't Michael make it a circle?
这盏灯不太好。但迈克尔也真的很挣扎。菲利斯和鲍勃超过了他。我是说，他躺在地上。他的嘴唇都白了。看起来不太好。他看起来撑不下去了。与此同时，托比赢得了比赛。是的。我觉得凯利在终点线看手机真是太完美了。是的。他问，我们在哪？她说，我们离办公室还有五公里。托比说，为什么迈克尔不把它设成一个圆圈？
No. I couldn't have made it easy. He made it a straight line. Well, it's interesting. So, that spot where they are is pretty much right outside of our real office, actually. That was on Sattacois Street where we shot. So we actually were very, very close. Like we just walked back to set at the end. Yeah. So we actually did end very close to our office. You know, I guess it's interesting because Pam, like, I think she's going to give Michael a pep talk, but she's like, no, you don't got this.
不。我不可能让它变得简单。他把它设成了一条直线。嗯，这很有趣。所以，他们所在的地方其实就在我们真正的办公室外面。我们是在萨塔科伊斯街拍摄的。所以我们实际上离得很近。就像我们在最后走回片场一样。是的。所以我们确实在离办公室很近的地方结束了。你知道，我想这很有趣，因为帕姆，我想她本来要给迈克尔打气，但她说，不，你做不到。
It's more like Pam's ass of like, there's other people that are better at helping people. Why don't you just let this one go? And then Michael's like, you don't know me. You've just seen my penis. And somehow, Pam not cheering him on makes him cheer himself on. And he has this talking head where he's like, finishing that 5K was the hardest thing I've ever had to do. I ate more Fetuccini Alfredo and drank less water than he ever. has in his entire life. This was so funny to me. He slowly makes his way across the finish line
更像是帕姆那种态度，比如，有其他人更擅长帮助别人。你为什么不放过这一次呢？然后迈克尔说，你不了解我。你只见过我的阴茎。不知何故，帕姆没有为他加油，反而让他为自己加油。他有一个谈话头镜头，他说，跑完那5公里是我做过最难的事情。我吃了比以往任何时候都多的意大利宽面条，喝的水却比以往任何时候都少。这对我来说太搞笑了。他慢慢地穿过终点线，
and I caught a palm tree. Yeah. Did you see it? Yes, I did. Yeah. 39 minutes, 46 seconds. Palm Tree alert. We did not. I guess we didn't paint that one out. Yeah. I'm sure there are others along the way because, you know, we're filming outside so much. But he finally makes it across the finish line. and Jim gives him the lamp as a trophy, and he pukes. Yeah, probably some kind of mushroom soup. Oh, it looked, it looked gross. It was so gross. It looked so gross.
我抓拍到了一棵棕榈树。是的。你看到了吗？是的，我看到了。是的。39分46秒。棕榈树警报。我们没有。我想我们没把那个修掉。是的。我相信沿途还有其他的，因为，你知道，我们在外面拍了太多戏。但他终于穿过了终点线，吉姆把灯当作奖杯给了他，然后他吐了。是的，可能是某种蘑菇汤。噢，看起来，看起来很恶心。太恶心了。看起来太恶心了。
And he let it just dribble down his chin. I'm like, wipe that off your face. So gross. Well, this episode ends with Michael in the hospital, and Meredith has wheeled herself in to his room to visit him. Yes. there is a deleted scene that Michael checked himself into the hospital for dehydration. And he requested his childhood pediatrician come visit him.
他让它顺着下巴流下来。我说，把那擦掉。太恶心了。嗯，这一集以迈克尔在医院结束，梅雷迪思坐着轮椅来到他的病房看望他。是的。有一个被删减的场景是迈克尔因为脱水住进了医院。他要求他儿时的儿科医生来看望他。
And his pediatrician is a very elderly man. And he's saying, you know, Michael doesn't really need to be in the hospital. He got a little dehydrated. Really, this all could have been solved with a bottle of water. But, and then as he's talking, Michael's like, where's my lollipop? He like gives him a... Oh, my gosh. So is that why he has a lollipop in this scene with Meredith?
他的儿科医生是一位非常年长的老人。他说，你知道，迈克尔其实不需要住院。他只是有点脱水。真的，这一切只要一瓶水就能解决。但是，当他说话时，迈克尔说，我的棒棒糖呢？他给了他一个……天哪。所以这就是为什么他在和梅雷迪思的那一幕里有棒棒糖吗？
Yes, because his pediatrician stopped by and checked in on him and gave him a lollipop. Well, the lollipop leads us to a very cringy final moment. Yes. Which is that Michael is sucking on the lollipop. And he suggests that they share it. So he hands it to Meredith, who then sort of puts it in her mouth. And then she offers it back to Michael and he says, nah, no, I'm good. I'm good.
是的，因为他的儿科医生顺道来看望他并给了他一根棒棒糖。嗯，棒棒糖把我们带到了一个非常尴尬的最后时刻。是的。那就是迈克尔在吮吸棒棒糖。他建议他们分享。于是他把它递给梅雷迪思，梅雷迪思把它放进嘴里。然后她把它递回给迈克尔，他说，不，不用了。我很好。
Good. Well, we had some mail from Eliza Jarvis and Natalie Benari. Please tell me the lollipop Michael shares with Meredith is switched out before they share it. Did they really share it? Guys, I wondered the same thing. When I watched this scene, there is no cut. It's a oneer shot of Steve taking the lollipop out of his mouth and handing it to Kate. So we asked Kate about it.
好的。嗯，我们收到了伊丽莎·贾维斯和娜塔莉·贝纳里的来信。请告诉我迈克尔和梅雷迪思分享的棒棒糖在分享前换过了。他们真的分享了吗？伙计们，我也想知道同样的事情。当我看到这一幕时，没有剪辑。这是一个长镜头，史蒂夫把棒棒糖从嘴里拿出来递给凯特。所以我们问了凯特这件事。
We had to ask her about it. And she said they did not rinse it off. She also said Steve improvised that in the moment and she just went with it. Yeah. And I think that's why you see her pause. a second. I think you are watching Kate the person decide if she's going to do this. Yeah. She's like, am I going to do this? But brilliant ending. Good for you, Kate. Way to really go for it on the show. She said she got a thrill out of doing your own sort of stunts. So yeah. Well, she's brave. And you know, there was a Dwight deleted talking head that I think would have come after this where. It's really, it kind of broke my heart where he talks about forgiveness and what it is to
我们不得不问她。她说他们没有冲洗。她还说史蒂夫是即兴发挥的，她就顺着演了。是的。我想这就是为什么你看到她停顿了一秒。我想你看到的是凯特本人在决定她是否要这样做。是的。她心想，我要这样做吗？但结局很精彩。干得好，凯特。在节目中真的很拼。她说她从做自己的特技中获得了快感。所以是的。嗯，她很勇敢。而且你知道，有一个德怀特被删减的谈话头镜头，我想应该是在这之后，它真的，它让我有点心碎，他谈到了宽恕以及什么是
forgive someone and that he hopes that his friend will forgive him because if Meredith can forgive Michael for hitting her with a car, maybe his friend will be able to forgive him and he's hopeful. I know. It made me sad. Yeah. Well, I think. That finishes out Fun Run. We did a Fun Run. Thank you guys so much for joining us for the Michael Scott, DMSMP, M-Rabies Awareness, Pro-Am Fun Run Race for the cure. We'll be back next week.
宽恕某人，他希望他的朋友能原谅他，因为如果梅雷迪思能原谅迈克尔开车撞她，也许他的朋友也能原谅他，他充满希望。我知道。这让我很难过。是的。嗯，我想这就是《趣味跑》的结尾。我们做了一次趣味跑。非常感谢大家加入我们的迈克尔·斯科特DMSMP狂犬病意识职业业余趣味跑治愈赛。我们下周见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jen Officials. and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍·奥菲舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。